right it's now uh a little after nine: I
apologize for uh getting started a
little late um I'm going to call uh the
Judiciary Committee uh to order and uh
please uh rise and join me in pledge of
allegiance to
Flack Ali to the flag of the United
States of America
and to the for stands one nation under
God indivisible withy and justice for
all all right um the first matter on for
hearing is House Bill uh
102 and I'm going to recognize uh the
prime sponsor representative Caitlyn
kouta representative
kout
good morning thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee I'm here today to introduce a
bill relative to the right to no
law currently our
law doesn't Define although the
Constitution says that we shall not
unreasonably restrict records we don't
Define what reasonable is so what that's
resulted in
is the ability to
make enormous
requests and that ability also branches
out to outof State businesses to also
make rather large requests because
perhaps perhaps those
requests benefit them financially to get
data that they could then sell
products and so what this bill seeks to
do is to help to define a little bit
more what reasonable is and part of the
reason for doing it is because towns
have become
so buried in these large requests that
then when somebody's trying to get a
really reasonable small request they're
waiting a really long time to get it and
we' we've got to fix that because when
people need something they should be
able to get it so this is trying to seek
to balance that so what this says is
that if the time to make a record
available is greater than 10 hours in a
one- month time
period Then the then the body May charge
up to $25 an hour to make that record
available and in
surveying through nhma and the school
board Association the the towns and the
school districts there weren't many
requests that did exceed that amount so
I don't expect this to end
up costing many people any money at all
it's it's really just for the large
requests and balancing and and balancing
out what we're requesting at the same
time this also seeks to put in here that
a public body or agency may suggest to a
requester a reasonable modification of
the scope of the request if doing so
would enable the body or agency to
produce the records more efficiently and
affordably and that's so that we're
working together in the spirit of how
it's intended to
be and I am happy to take any questions
on the
bill questions for uh the
sponsor yes representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question my concern is that this hurts
the little guy
um there's nothing in here that I read
but correct me if I'm wrong that I mean
you can't go by hours because you could
have someone who um takes two hours to
do that task and another person that
would take 10 hours to do that P task it
depends
on you know what they want how fast they
want to do it how able they are to do it
so doing it by hours is to me
is very arbitrary and I have a concern
about that because if you're putting
stuff together for me in the
municipality and you don't like me you
could take a lot longer and that stuff
happens all the time so that's my
concern that this hurts the little guy
thank you for that question so that was
actually raised and I did pass around an
amendment to this um and what that is
saying is that if a party believes that
the estimated number of hours or cost to
make the records available as
unreasonable that they may file a
complaint with the EMB budsman for
determination whether the estimate is
reasonable and to be clear really what
we're talking about here is this $25
isn't going to even cover the cost of it
because a lot of times what this is is
having to have records redacted by an
attorney at a rate of $350 an hour so
this isn't even going to cover the
actual cost of making many of these
records available so if it's something
where a municipal worker is putting this
together and they're not even actually
having to have an attorney redact it you
know I think if they're if they're
putting together estimates that are
unreasonable certainly the EMB budsman
could step in and put that put that
forward I think if you're paying an
attorney an hourly rate to to redact
stuff I think I mean they've got
professional conduct to make sure that
they're they're giving an accurate
estimate in
it
yes thank you
um $25 an hour is a lot of money for
people today especially and I you always
hear me talk about the little guy the
guy who's going to work putting gas in
his car trying to feed his family clothe
his family and
time they don't have time to go the next
step or the money to go to a lawyer or
this and that I think once again this
can really hurt the people that this
91a those are the people that it's
supposed to help and I think this really
hurts it it hurts them because you're
charging them you have no way of knowing
what it actually takes to do and you're
expecting them to follow up if they
think it's unreasonable and personally I
just
think um it hurts a little guy but thank
you right other questions for this word
yes representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative um my kind of along
the same lines representative Perez one
of my concerns is um a town can possibly
make it a discriminatory practice to
charge some and not others um and I'm
concerned about the Civil Rights
implications of that
and would you be open or is there any
way to add language to make sure that
you
know I'm concerned that if if the town
thinks that something is
politically um unreasonable the town
employees decide that it is and then
they decide that something else is
reasonable I'm afraid that you know
there might be some
political um push back depending on what
the request
is thank you for that question so I'd be
happy to put something in here that that
about relative to the public bodies
developing a policy so that it's more
consistent the reason why I use the word
may is that perhaps you have somebody
that comes in and that the town knows
that that maybe that person has gotten a
a tax abatement for the year and they
financially this might be a hardship to
them and they're trying to work with
them and they don't want to charge them
I didn't want to say that they shall
charge I wanted to give them the
opportunity to do that but to make it
more consistent I'd be open to
discussing potentially putting something
in there that they had to develop a
policy on it if that would would that
make you feel better well just to follow
up I not that I'm advocating for this
but if you put sh at least it's like
uniform across the board but when you
say may it opens it up to some sort of a
town bureaucrat deciding that they're
going to charge this person because they
don't agree with the politics of the
right to no request and not charge this
person that's my
concern so perhaps to balance that we
could say shell in there and then we
could say that maybe something along the
lines of the Town may choose to wave
this fee if the party is is Indigent of
some sort like some some way of putting
that in there well I'm I'm I'm gonna let
the public hearing continue but now it's
we're in control of the bill so just a
suggestion that's all other questions
yes representative M thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I had
assumed when I read uh the bill that the
May applied to keeping a local option
for municipalities and towns to decide
whether they wanted to charge or not
charge whether it would be $25 an hour
or some lesser amount and that the towns
would have the option to set a uniform
policy it didn't occur to me as I read
this that it would be on an instance by
instance judgment so I'm just wondering
if you could comment on
that so I think it could be interpreted
either way so I think if if that's a
concern I think we could definitely
clarify the language a bit I I do I do
think it's a bit ambiguous with that
with that terminology so I think we
could clarify that a
bit other questions for this uh yes
representative Stapleton and then
representative CH thank you and thank
you for taking my question on page two
uh line four multiple request from any
person or entity to the same public body
within a 30-day time period shall be
considered one request but what was the
purpose um of putting a group
like that U does that represent
difficulty for the town or
municipality thank you for the question
so the purpose of that was just that if
you asked for a request that took 10
hours that you didn't get that request
and then go back the next day and then
ask for another 10 hours worth
of research and data if you wanted
to really again like part of my goal
here is that many of the of the public
bodies are now backed up with right to
no requ quests they can't answer them as
quickly as they'd like to because they
are backed up and so I was trying to
Define what a
reasonable amount of time would be for a
request and I think 10 hours worth of
data in a 30-day time period is a is a
pretty substantial amount
of time put into requesting it and so
that was really the purpose give
somebody else a chance to get the data
that they need as well I mean we've got
you know if a newspaper is putting in a
right to no request for example
and they can't get the stuff back for
two months I mean that's no longer news
anymore once it's the story is two
months old so I want to make sure that
we're able to to quickly serve everybody
we're working together on this thank you
representative
tur yeah thanks for taking the question
sorry I'm a bit late I hope this hasn't
been covered um but I was wondering on
on the last page uh Section 8 um where
it talks about the reasonable charge may
be made for employee time time um I'm my
understanding is sometimes this is also
uh particularly for the redaction and
the the the legal thing uh aspects chart
uh the town will um involve the town um
Council so I didn't know whether that
was something that you'd considered
whether or not that would be part of of
the fees associated with these requests
yeah so that was part of it and again
that won't cover the full amount often
these attorneys are charging 350 an hour
and this is only two 25 an hour hour um
but I didn't want to make
it unaffordable for anybody to possibly
get data that they may need yeah what
one quick f i what what I was really
saying is it says employee time I didn't
know whether that needed to be broadened
in order to allow for for um
non-employees that the town might
contract to to take care of these
requests thank you for the question yeah
let me let me look into that because
that perhaps that needs a little bit of
clarifying thank you for the question
appreciate it other question yes
representative
trip thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh it appears that
there's some fear that there's going to
be discriminatory practices on uh the
cost of uh fulfilling these
requests
uh my question is if you are concerned
with this would it be possible to make
an RSA 91a request to to find out
what the costs of other requests are so
that you could determine whether there
is or is not discriminatory practices
thank you for the question yes you could
absolutely put in that to see what
others have been charged and if they had
been if it was being unfairly put in
absolutely thank you other questions for
this
witness great thank you very much thank
you U next I'm going to call on uh
representative Andrew
please
good morning colleagues my name is
representative Louise Andress I
represent rayat County District 5 andova
danur Hill Salsbury and Webster but I am
here today representing myself on this
bill our New Hampshire
Constitution states article eight
accountability of magistrates offices
Public's right to know all power
residing originally in and being derived
from the
people all the magistrates and offices
of government are their substitutes and
agents and at all times accountable to
them amended 1976 by providing right of
access to governmental proced
proceedings and
Records yet this bill is taking away
these rights in my
opinion many people that ask for
information ask for it they can't get it
from an a public office so then they
have to do a right to know many people
cannot afford to pay fees and they
shouldn't have
to I have asked for information from my
town my school district quite
often and
nobody usually gives asks for
fees I realize once in a
while there are people that are
excessive in asking for information how
we balance that I don't have the answer
but the ordinary citizen has a right to
know what's going on in any public
office and that information is
theirs our taxes pay for those employees
working in those
places our taxes pay for all the paper
all the copying everything we shouldn't
have to pay double
fees
also in the Hampshire law and this is
where I don't know if this a
contradiction in RSA
32 excuse me
3210 it
states that in a budget committee or a
citizen can
ask their school district for a transfer
of
funds I have done that to my school
district
recently there are so many things that
go on in our government and when like a
budget is handed to us from our school
district those total figures mean
actually
nothing and sometimes people want to dig
in to know what's going on and unless
you do a right to know
request nobody will answer you now I
have an a right to no request into my
school district right now but transfer
of funds because there's so many
millions of dollars that are
transferred now they are not going to
charge
me it's going to take 60 days which I
told them was fine but I want the
information and I have that right I
believe if we start charging fees and
making laws that everybody's going to
pay for this and that we are taking away
our rights of our citizens of New
Hampshire and we can't do it and so in
the end I'm asking you to itl this Bill
thank you questions for this witness
representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question do you think
if municipalities or whatever people
were more
transparent and better about answering
requests there would be a lot less
91a because I know people in my town
have asked for information
maybe because I'm a rep they're pretty
good about giving it to me but they
don't get it and that's why they file a
91a and that this would hurt those
people whereas if the town was just more
transparent and said yes I can get that
information for you you wouldn't even
have to file a 91a your
thoughts I think it depends on the
municip municipality or the school
district I mean some municip ality no
matter what you ask them you get the
information and the next municipality it
might be so political that they don't
want to give out information I look at
life this way and this is just my
opinion if they don't want to give out
information what are they trying to hide
that's just
me other questions for this witness all
right thank you very much representative
Andrew all right uh next I'm going to
call on uh representative Michael K
pleas
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Michael Cahill I represent the
towns of newfields and New Market in
Rockingham 10 and I'm a co-sponsor of
this bill as are so many other people
listed at the top they've almost run out
of room uh and they're co-sponsoring
because this is an issue that does
affect taxpayers uh residents and VAR
many communities uh who are asked to pay
for legal costs cost of of producing
information often times uh it's
weaponized the the right to no law is
weaponized so as to inflict cost and and
uh it said Vendetta against a perceived
grievance you know to address a
perceived grievance
um in my community we had The Misfortune
of uh having a a disgruntled former
employee set set his sights upon uh New
Market and every every current and and
uh future superintendent school board
member because the person lost his job
he went to the uh um uh public Labor
Relations Board lost there and took 91a
as his Avenue of
Revenge and this is not the routine this
is not how the the law was intended to
be used it was intended for citizens to
gather information that they that they
feel is uh
unavailable otherwise and for the
municipalities to provide it uh which I
think is a normal normal occurrence and
now if there are people who uh uh ask
for qu ask for information and don't
receive it promptly uh maybe they need
to make uh not request everything quite
so
broadly uh all the rec all the emails
ever sent to and from anyone in the in
the municipality or school or or super
us
um or School District you know it's it's
a bit
excessive um hypothetically
hypothetically now what if a person were
what if a person uh were not satisfied
with the information they were getting
and understood that they were costing
the district a quite a quite a bit of
money said to them uh well you know I
know you're you may be getting weary of
this and and I could use a little
money and would that what would that
would that be construed as some sort of
coercion uh
extortion
blackmail intimidation is that is that
uh legal and and just for questioning
that sort of thing just for raising that
point uh this might lead to a whole
search of uh law enforcement uh emails
and uh records and time sheets and all
manner of things in order to inflict
cost on the on the community now we
worried about taxpayers being able to
afford to pay $25 in the event that
their request takes more than 10 hours
we have taxpayers paying uh the cost of
these sometimes frivolous requests and
this money would obviously be going
toward other uh uh purposes that are
benefit to the community uh speaking of
communities I know we had we had an
email from someone talking about how uh
V there's a ruling in Virginia that
their uh that their rights to no request
are only for citizens of Virginia our
law does not is not that specific it's
citizens of the world I don't know so we
do get requests from all over the
country asking for for the curricula uh
in in the public school and why is that
of interest to someone in Las Vegas or
usbekistan or
anywhere uh so that the law it's a good
law but it has has been weaponized and
it needs a bit of Revision in order to
pull in the scope and to make it a more
userfriendly uh more
accommodating uh law when needed and and
it may not be that it's needed all the
time if you simply say i' like this
information and the clerk says it's on
this website and this here's the page
here's the link to it you don't need to
file a right to no request if you ask
for something and you feel the person is
uh uh not giving you exactly what what
you want then you can do the right to no
request but again ask for what you want
and and I know we don't we can't ask why
so it's not on a need to know basis is I
want to know so uh I support the bill
and I I hope that uh the committee will
work hard to make any necessary changes
but in the end do something because we
have we have a serious problem we may
not the communities may not want to
advertise just how much this is costing
them so is not to incentivize further uh
frivolous
requests that concludes my testimony
thank you questions for this witness
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question is the example
you gave the exception or the
rule uh well I'm looking at the number
of co-sponsors here and I'm thinking
it's a l it's not quite the exception
and nor the rule but it's frequent
enough to bring in uh members of the
other body who uh I think were were
interested in this issue for some time
and uh it's a bipartisan concern so I
wouldn't say that it's the exception and
I wouldn't say it's the rule but it does
happen other questions for this follow
yeah would you be comfortable if the
rule or the the amendment said
for Citizens or companies outside of New
Hampshire charge the companies that want
big stuff and not charge the citizen
would would something like that appeal
to you
uh I I think there may still be citizens
who would in fact abuse the the law so I
I think a fee you know when something
costs there there are costs involved and
to recover a small portion of the cost
uh I think is reasonable I I do see I
did hear that the you know the
the concern about sh and May and and you
know could it be this way and that way
you know you're try if you're trying to
do enabling
legislation you know you don't want to
say shall but you want to say that you
may do it but the degree to which you do
it or how you're do it in the
community it gets a little it gets a
little challenging there I do think the
idea of saying shall uh establish a
policy and have it consistent I think
that could that could be a step although
I heard a something about indigence and
can you make an exception but you have
to be careful making an exception
because it might be
discriminatory the law is uh as some of
you know uh very difficult to uh design
and Implement and and
follow other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you sir um you know what can I ask
is um we generally uh accommodate other
representativ so are there other
Representatives here who who wish to
test testify um we'll take you out of
order if you if you're
here yes please come
up have you given you've given us a card
right yeah yes please yeah please if you
would good morning Mr chairman members
of the Judiciary
Committee got a lot of documents here
and I'm not going to read them to you
this is just for show this is a partial
right to no request and I'm I'm a
mechanic by trade so I'm going to just
give you a couple examples of what I've
been through in Rochester and why the
right to noar it's good to hear the
questioning because several of you know
how valuable the right to noar is and
with newspapers going out it's becoming
it's St starting to fall more and more
on the citizen to keep their government
accountable and right now if we find a
problem with the right to no law we've
got to take him to court and that can
cost up to
$450 if you represent yourself and I
understand that the city of Rochester is
taking the Rochester voice to court over
an issue of what who is a citizen and
the county of marac waved the fee to the
city so the can cities take people Court
over the right to know and at no cost
and citizens they have to pay
$450 is that right you know that that's
what I heard and the the editor of the
Rochester voice is here today and I'll
say I count on his blog if you will a
newspaper to get my information on
what's going on in the city and I'll
share with you how important the right
to olar is from past experience in
2010 the city of Rochester brought
forward a comprehensive resoning 132
page
document they worked on it for almost 9
years they couldn't provide any minutes
to any meetings that they had in those
nine years to discuss the comprehensive
resoning I took that to the at the time
the state had redress grievances
committee and we had eight or nine hours
of testimony the city's excuse was we
never had a quorum so we never had a
meeting and I said then how did did this
132 page document come where did this
come from if you never met so they
finally admitted that they were wrong
and as a result they had to do it over
and it took them three more years to do
it over but when they did it over they
had public hearings they had minutes and
the citizens got to see what was going
on and it made a change and a lot of
stuff was changed that's one example now
recently I took the the uh I filed the
right to0 request to the city City and
uh this is an example of what you go
through and by the way the city of
Rochester all right to no request go
right to the City
attorney they don't go to the if they go
to whatever Department you ask for
information it all goes to the City
attorney and I'm going to give you an
example I asked for uh the uh three
requests request all government
documents and Communications including
emails between the DPW Director City
manager and City attorney separate
separately or collectively between each
and All Above named persons from August
15th to September 15
2023 um what I got was a catch initially
within 10 days I got a small maybe six
or seven pieces one of the things I was
looking for is a a man died on Main
Street in
Rochester he was on a motorcycle and he
got hit by a car and the the traffic
lights were not functioning and they
hadn't been for some time and trying to
find out what the heck happened and what
the city was doing about it I'm on
public works and highways committee I
wanted to be able to compare so I got a
a small amount of information $3 worth
and it had the dispatch and it had one
Memo from the uh uh though I just got
dispatched at that time and in dispatch
several of the people called and said
there's going to be an accident you got
to do something about these law
so then I made a WR to all request and
then uh the city provided 339
pages but I didn't get these till
November and I filed the request October
10th so I paid $42 for and this 332
pages but if it was a book it would be
twice as many
pages and it wouldn't be a bestseller I
can assure you of that so they said well
we've got more information coming for
you I said Okay I want it so I got
another uh 902
pages and and this amount just covered
from August 15th to August
24th and the rest of it was from August
25th to September 15 902 Pages or
1,800 uh uh 92 or 1800 pages so a total
of 2500 pages I got and several of them
that I got were just email warnings they
had you know nothing on them one or two
sentences I was charged 10 cents a page
for that copy this amount of pages I
paid for cost me half of what I get paid
as a state representative to get this
information and that's that's kind of
what's going on here in the city so to
get to the bill when you say things like
in an estimate of the cost of making
that record available if a charge would
be incurred in Rochester you've got a
City attorney who can charge billable
hours to to Citizens trying to get
information and it you could very easily
with what you've seen here he could
easily run into 10 hours so you ask for
stuff and it's going to be
$250 that's you can't have that you
can't have that not in the right to know
because it's going to be the citizens of
the first line of defense to find out
what their government's up to Foster's
Daily Democrat was a a very well- noted
paper and I talked to a a editorial
manager he worked there in the 70s and '
80s he said we had 44 reporters back
then you're lucky if there's four now so
what's going to get out there about
stuff that's going
on and uh you know I I I'll give you an
example some questions I asked and how
they reply to it because I think it's
important a request this was the
December 11th 20 uh 23 request I made I
wanted to know more about the right to
know and Rochester to find out because
we're hearing all these cities are
overwhelmed they can't keep up blah blah
blah all these requests so I asked all
government documents emails regarding
the cost of Personnel hours travel
research and any other cost and or
payments made associated with the right
to know on budsman case between the city
and the Rochester voice and any further
actions and cost on this issue to date
now the Rochester voice is here he took
the city to court with the Ombudsman in
a very interesting
case uh what the City attorney his
response to my that right to no request
was no governmental records exist
responsive to this request he doesn't
know how much it cost for him and his
assistant to go Testify the UN budsman
doesn't know how much research cost and
this is the guy that will be making
estimates for this bill that you're
bringing forward so the second request
made to the city for this calendar year
these government records uh I ask for
all right to no requests made to the
city for this calendar year to date
these governmental records are not
readily available for inspection the
city requires 30 days to compile the
governmental records and prepare them
for public inspection 30 days you don't
think they can find 10 billable hours in
30 days ladies and gentlemen this is
what we're look this is what we're
facing and the third request the total
cost of the legal department for this
calendar year for handling processing
and answering all right to no request
submitted to the city his reply no
governmental records exist responsive to
this request and this gentleman has done
this repeatedly to write to no request
that's the first line of defense no
government records
exist I had an issue where the city did
Capital reserves and the amount of the
three of them in the amount of million5
500,000 for each I asked the the uh city
under the right to know it had been a
while since it was voted on I did not
see the money get transferred to the
trustees of the trust fund I asked under
the right to know where is that money
where is that million five and I got the
request no no government records exist
on that and I I had to argue with them I
said well they got to exist because the
state law says the treasurer shall have
accounting of all monies at all times
so they got to know where that million
five is and I want to know where it is
and then they change their tune and this
is what you dealing with when you get
to having
somebody figure out billable hours and
the other thing is allowing them to
change what you're asking for by
allowing them to to uh as as the bill
said allowing them to I'm paraphrasing
to work with you to adjust it well how
what's to say they don't adjust it so
they don't give you what you want and
they change it to something else and
then if you don't agree with them then
you got to go to court the only
resolution to the right to know is to
take them to
court that's all you can do and uh the
Rochester voice again I count on him for
information and the problem he had with
the uh and I hope you guys address this
is a word Citizen and the Ombudsman in
his in his uh ruling he's felt that the
Rochester voice had standing and he
mentioned in there how it doesn't matter
anybody can ask for information and get
it and that was in the ruling and he
cited a case I think from 2018 of the
Supreme Court that had that his an email
he sent December 28th and the Rochester
voice guide maybe he'll count on that so
it was to Harrison th and his this is
from the city attorney on on City
attorney email as you very well know the
city's position is that you as a citizen
of Maine are not entitled to any rights
granted under RSA 91 A4 including
receiving a response within five
business days the right to no law is
clear it's uh 91
a43 you they if they can't provide the
information they shall notify you in
writing within five days and this is the
City attorney telling somebody who had
made a right to know
request including receiving you are not
entitled to any rights including
receiving a response within five
business days now I'll close by
saying in Rochester
our our information people which is it
which is the city clerk's office and the
city attorney's office their budget is
$2.4 million a
year if they're having trouble getting
information that need they need to work
with their with their it to get their to
get their business together so they can
get the information out which is the
people's information in a timely manner
and I think they can do that I think
2.33 million goes a long ways so the
rest of the information I got they
wanted another $92 for me for the F for
the 1,800 pages
so they they wanted o o over half of
what I get paid as a state route to get
information that should have been
readily available all right questions
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you oh I'm
sorry uh representative D Loreno thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um could you introduce yourself
I didn't get your name oh I'm sorry uh
state representative Cliff Newton
district 6 Rochester New Hampshire oh
thank you so um here's my question from
all the material that was given to you
by the city of Rochester did you find
the information you were looking for
about this much but I didn't know I was
just one memo explaining the accident
that I didn't get I asked for uh uh um
standard operating procedure for the
city when there were traffic issues when
there were roads out and stuff I never
got that basically what I got I got 30
pages of uh quick claim deeds I got
multiple copies of the same thing I got
uh multiple pages with just one sentence
an email email warning on them so I got
you know a lot of it was waste I'd say
maybe out of maybe out of uh 1,400 pages
I might have got 120 that I had interest
in that weren't directly I got dates
that weren't were relevant to what I
asked for and on and on so what if we're
going to pay them to do research and
this is an example of the research
you're doing it it's it's bad it's bad
may I follow up yes please thank you so
then um you mentioned some dates uh
towards the end of 2023 you said
December 11th and you made some um
requests in the month of December did
you do more than one during that month
did I do what did you do more than one
right to know request within no I did
that in response to what I got from the
other ones it usually when you do a
right to0 request it leads to more
questions because you get information
that you you in the right to no request
you're you're asking for something you
don't have the documents in front of so
you don't know exactly what you're going
to get until they give it to you all
right thank you y thank you other
representative stapled thank you for
taking my question
um this bill does it answer the needs uh
or some of the needs that you've
described here or not uh what's your
position on that I don't support this
bill at all because I feel it weakens
the right to no
law thank you and I think the right to
no law is very important right other
questions for this witness all right
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you
um next I'm gonna
uh oh yes I'm G to call on
representative grassy
please and you know just just uh we have
a number of other Witnesses who wish to
testify and obviously we're running late
which is fine but I just ask you to
everyone to please keep your testimony
to about 3 minutes or so I I wasn't
planning on testifying at all Mr
chairman but I sat in the room listen to
this I'm representative Chuck Rassy I
represented Rochester wood4 and um I
will tell you that uh I co-sponsored
this bill and one of the reasons why I
co-sponsored this bill is because when I
um heard talk about a bill coming in to
deal with this issue with uh what we
call dilatory request under the right to
no law I was talking to with members of
the school department and they have
actually a file draw which has dozens
and dozens and dozens of thumb drives
and files paper files probably thousands
of pages which have been requested and
never picked
up so this is you know that's a
obviously request that was made just to
waste people's time having worked in
municipal government for quite a number
of years as well I know that when you
get a right to no request you make every
effort you can to get it and then you
get a question you get a request which
is
maybe not specific to something but but
very vague and you try to answer as best
you can can and you get three more
requests because you didn't answer it
the way they wanted you to answer it and
and and I think that that's what we see
a lot and particularly in Rochester I
will tell you having served on the city
council there for over 30 years and been
a state representative there for 18
years I will tell you that the people in
the city of Rochester work hard we have
fewer staff than most other communities
of similar size and I the the members of
the city clerk's office who put this in
information together do the best they
can I know that they've moved a lot of
stuff over to the attorney's office
because a lot of the requests that have
been dilatory and have been just to take
up your time uh the requests many times
are vague you try to answer them uh and
it's not it's not accepted so you get
more requests and a lot of times these
requests that come in that when people
don't even come and pick up the
information so you know that this is a
problem and it's something that
certainly has to be done dealt with I
would be happy to tell you the story
that representative Newton addressed as
far as the the zoning requirements we
actually had a subcommittee and
interesting thing it was the gentleman I
ran against in the two Thai elections
that I just had he and I were two
members of the five members of that
committee Mr Newton was a third member
of that committee we never could get a
quorum so we basically worked on it
between the two of us and when they were
you know we got 5 years down the road we
said hey look we've been waiting long
enough here's the work that we have but
we were never able to get a quorum at
any of our meetings so we never had
minutes if you don't have a quorum you
don't have a meeting so but the thing is
is that sometimes the the questions are
vague for a reason because they just
want to take up your time thank you Mr
shamman thank you uh questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
um next I'm going to call on Susan Rice
please and I'm gonna uh ask you to
please limit your remarks to 3 minutes
cuz we do have a lot of witnesses and I
want to get through everybody thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and I will try to honor your request
hello my name is Susan Rice I reside at
1591 Rod Road in Rochester New Hampshire
I had a career in public service I was
an employee I've also been an elected
and appointed official and now a
resident and business owner in Rochester
an opportunity of a lifetime occurred at
the age of 18 to testify in Superior
Court in the total I have been involved
in four major land use court cases I do
owe my education to Attorney Peter
Laughlin and attorney SAR calman they
drilled me and schooled me in RSA
91a and it was reinforced with the
attorney general's memo of March 20th
2015 the schooling I received allowed
one particular businessman and also
several other businessmen to continue
their business operations because I was
able to give them information under 91a
requests that is what is called Public
Service the New Hampshire Constitution
and the right of right to no law ensure
that the public has reasonable access to
meetings of public bodies and to
governmental records in 1976 the people
of New Hampshire amended our
constitutional government therefore it
should be open accessible accountable
and responsive and to that end the
Public's right of access to governmental
proceedings and Records shall not be
unreasonably restricted the RSA is clear
on this subject and I'm going to skip
ahead head so that you can get more of a
perspective of what I've recently gone
through in Rochester I recently
requested informational exchanges
emails from the mayor to a city employee
for a period of 30
days in the end I received
198 Pages some double-sided some knot
and was charged for
448 Pages or
$488 cents ironically this was nothing
more than an absolute pile of bull
and 99% of it was not what I had
asked for completely off topic the same
request was placed by another person and
that person received approximately 60
pages of information he requested I
received from the city attorney excuses
of malfunctioning computer software an
excuse of 30 to 45 days after the
information download to review for
redaction and what I've seen so far
there is not one redaction in this and
most infuriating I only received 198
Pages many of which were single-sided
this is clearly an excellent example of
incompetence by a highly educated fool a
public body or agency may suggest to the
requestor a reasonable modification of
the scope of a
request these visions of our
Constitution and RSA 91a are intended to
provide the utmost information to the
people about what their government is
doing while preserving individual rights
to privacy something I value very highly
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
recognized that the right to no law
helps to carry out the Constitution's
requirement you know what Ram you've
arrived at the three minute Mark so I'm
going to ask you to please sum up oh
okay my next sentence you cannot fix
stupid in my recent encounter with the
city attorney and I would not trust him
to ask me for a summary of what I would
need thank you very much questions for
this
witness being none thank you very much
I'm going to next call on Giles
pet
Mr chair yes um if the witness has
written testimony knowing that we will
read that testimony could you ask him to
just give us the highlights and not read
that thank you no that's a very good
suggestion thank you I'm I'm sure Mr
biset will will keep his remarks within
the time thank you absolutely I know uh
I know I know the committee's already
running over uh jel Binet legal director
of the ACLU of New Hampshire strongly in
opposition uh to this legis ation um I
do want to be very clear and I know this
goes back to the representative
statements about the the little guy how
would this impact regular requesters
this would have a direct impact on
regular requesters and it would deter uh
I think even um modest requests because
what I think was generally going to
happen if this bill is passed you put a
request in there'll be General
overestimates concerning how long things
will take which we already see right now
we see overestimates concerning how long
documents will take from a response time
perspective to be delivered and this
will just pile on that level of
uncertainty you'll be told things may
take 10 20 30 hours and what that will
do is even if it's a modest request it
will deter the requestor from moving
forward because they know gosh I'm going
to get a bill for several hundred doll
and that is incredibly problematic so I
just want to be very clear I know the
intent behind this bill is to kind of
get at overb you know requests that are
perceived as over broad this is not just
going to address those requests it's
going to address even modded requests
and it goes so far as to even bill for
things like redactions I could just tell
you as someone that makes frequent
requests I get things that are heavily
redacted that I think are incredibly
problematic and that's because sometimes
not always but sometimes there are some
overzealous assertions of exemptions and
as a requester why should I have to pay
for that overzealous assertion of an
exemption through redactions that's
exact ly what would happen here and of
course too what this bill would do is
put the burden on requesters to pay for
bad document retention policies that
cities and towns may have you're now
having to pay um Municipal actors to go
get documents that may be hard to find
but maybe they shouldn't be hard to find
if you had better practices so I think
this is this is problematic on multiple
levels as echoed in my uh testimony I
think it's over Brad in many ways
there's no indigency uh exception it's
not limited to commercial reasons I know
it was one of the rationals proposed for
the law it's not limited to out ofate
persons none of those limitations should
be in the bill anyway um but I just
think that highlights uh the over breath
of this legislation and I I think the
Deep harm it would do to transparency
and accountability and I genuinely
believe that thank you questions for
this WT yes representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question thank you um my my concern
is along the same lines it's the
discriminatory practice and I guess I'm
wondering if the ACLU has any sort of
um information on how other states have
if they have a law like this in place if
they do and then how they've navigated
that sort of concern I have regarding um
discriminatory practice and I know on
the my second question is I know on the
last page you have um a fee waver for
indigents and I know there's um some
states that charge coffee costs but not
staff costs I guess I'm wondering like
if you have suggested language on
indigency too yeah I I don't I haven't
done a 50 state survey to be BL
um I I also want to be honest there are
there are some states that do this right
that charge for labor costs um and there
are many states like New Hampshire
currently that do not and I think we
should stay where we are so there are
states kind of all over the map on this
uh but with we are surrounded by some
neighboring states frankly that do
charge labor costs and I think
transparency has probably suffered as a
result if you talk to some of the
Advocates there so I don't think we
should copy that policy from from other
states and let's keep you know a good
part of our law intact and in fact I
would argue that there are many other
ways we should be making this law better
not worse other questions for this
witness yes representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question so am
I hearing you say that you believe the
right to L law should be the right to
low law as it exists and not the right
to know if you can afford it absolutely
absolutely thank you other questions for
this witness Mr chair yes yes
representative dorenzo uh thank you for
taking my question thank you so um could
you please tell me um overall we know
that there are people that abuse the law
um but then there are also honest
Earnest people so how do you balance all
of that yeah I you know I actually think
in many ways though it's not really
hasn't been reflected in the prior
testimony I think we actually have on
this front with respect to costs a good
balance there are still costs that think
that requesters have to bear in terms of
copy costs that is a real cost and I do
think even today that probably provides
some sort of filtering mechanism here
those costs can be as little as you can
get it for free some municipalities
permit it some 5 10 cents some upwards
of a dollar and the court has recognized
that those costs um are are not
unreasonable so I do think that is one
current mechanism we have where
requesters still actually have some sort
of skin in the game and of course
they're always are the provisions of RSA
918 that um if the request is frivolous
and there's ultimate litigation they
themselves would have to pay uh costs to
municipalities so I think a lot of that
is built in there are always going to be
examples on the margins and I think
that's just part of any type of
legislative regime and I think we are
hearing examples of you know what seemed
to be pretty excessive I would submit
they're in a minority of cases I could
recite and I wanton today time after
time of what I think are excessive
misuse of government agencies not biing
information um and I think that is kind
of the nature of the system but I don't
want the pendulum to swing towards
secrecy and that's what this bill would
do in my view okay thank you other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much next I'm going to
call on uh uh
Lori AA orano
sorry thank
you
and again ma' I'm just going to ask you
to limit your remarks to three minutes
and if you have written testimony we
will read it so please don't just read
your written testim okay thank you can
you hear me yes good I'm going to avoid
that and you do have my written
testimony and I'll submit it online my
name is Lori ortolano I'm from NASA I'm
a resident of right to know New
Hampshire and in 2023 I was an Honore
for the nacki lobe uh First Amendment
award and um this award was given to me
in recognition of the work I had done
starting in 2018 using the right to no
law to try and deal with assessing
issues down in nasua and it was quite a
battle um I'm in strong opposition I to
this bill um HB 102 for a number of
reasons on the surface it appears
reasonable but um I'm concerned about
discrimination and retaliation issues
that will result in this and the
targeting of individuals who are trying
to uncover wrongdoing that's going on in
a municipality Nashua has had a
four-year history of right to no
requests coming in to court with four or
five citizens and we've done pretty well
in battling the city on these issues
most of them prosay
um it's very difficult to go into court
on your own and try and deal with these
issues with a um City legal office that
is so non-transparent and opposed to
working with us and I want to just point
out an example of a case that recently
occurred to me that I think is exactly
the reason I don't want to see fees put
in I put in a request his collect video
surveillance um footage of me where the
city was capturing me in City Hall I had
requested surveillance video be stored
on me at certain occasions when the city
was trying to bring criminal charges
against me for going for information and
I got those tapes but I wanted I
wondered if they were doing others and I
got a response and I wrote my request to
say don't provide me with any videos
that you've already given me I don't
want to burden you with volume I got a
response back that there was over 15
gigs of data and I was really surprised
by that I thought wow they're taping me
a lot I went to the department knocked
on the door was able to get in and said
to the clerk you know are these all
videos that the city has produced on me
she said no there's only one all the
others we gave to you and I said well
did you repeat and give me all the data
you already gave me and she said yes
because the administration told us to
only read the first line of your request
and to ignore the rest of it so we
ignored it that's an act of bad faith
and I can tell you time and time again I
have seen this I want that shut down now
with regard to
um um tracking of costs the city early
on when I was doing the assessing work
was making public announcements that I
was costing the city hundreds of
thousands of dollars the mayor referred
to it as a million frustrated by hearing
this I put in a right to know get costs
what what where are they they had none
it was an estimate okay there's no
tracking at all um when it comes to
questions so this city absolutely
refuses to reduce the burden if you file
a right to know and say would you be
willing to work with me to reduce the
Bur
their answer is no okay I put in a right
to no request to receive emails on a new
market tax credit federal transaction
that was used to build the Performing
Art Center in nashwa and I got a
response back that it would take four
years to get them your it was ridiculous
I took it into court and the judge
Consolidated it into a larger case that
took is going to take two years to
hear I'm done I can't get the records
okay at that case is going to cost me
$10,000 if these fees that request if
you put these fees in line I'm I'm going
to be sunk and those emails uncovered
some criminal acts that are now before
the AG you know you're getting close to
your three minute line so I'd ask you to
sum up please so um questions the city
when we initially started these right to
no requests the city said to us they
would write back and say could you tell
us what you mean by this could you
explain further they would ask us
questions fine you'd write back and say
this is what I'm looking for but if we
wrote questions back to them and said
what do you expect or what's the volume
of data it doesn't sound like you're
summing up ma'am that's I'm I'm summing
up just to say that questioning the city
to reduce the burden is not a problem is
not is not done at all the response back
from the city is under RSA 91a we're not
required to answer questions so there's
a lot of bad faith and Bad actors down
in Nashua and I don't believe I'm a bad
actor going for data I believe I'm a
citizen really trying hard to understand
what my government's up to and there's
been some things that have not been so
cool and this kind of legislation is
going to hurt us I attached to my filing
a court order from Judge Temple where he
strongly wrote that the city is
violating My First Amendment rights that
it's not proper that they have to stop
doing that and work to fix the problems
that was written in July the needle
hasn't moved five degrees to correct
these issues this legis painful
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much man
thank you next I'm going to call on
Shannon Martinez
please sorry so I'm a little nervous so
I talk fast when I'm nervous so excuse
me okay all right so uh thank you for
the opportunity to speak and um for
contemplating this important matter I
think it's not an easy thing to
contemplate what the right
um balances when it comes to the right
to know so my name is Shannon Martinez
and I'm the town manager in ctie if I
had to sum up the way that I spent 2023
I would say right to nose in the
weaponization of right to nose in 2023
we processed just over 70 right to nose
several of the right to knows took over
30 hours to process moreover of their 70
right to knows several required multiple
responses because the community members
in question wanted to dialogue and not
not to request records themselves so we
processed way over the 70 requests 29 of
the right to no request we processed
were from the same person about the same
subject matter I estimate that in 2023 I
spent on average 5 hours a week on this
person's right to know requests and
subsequent emails this is 260 hours or
32.5 days I'm the highest paid employee
for the town of sentie and that's how I
spent one month of my um tenure this
year this hardly seems fair to Residents
who are seeking information on um other
matters that they're struggling with
concerning serious zoning issues um a
junkyard and other community members
wanting to move um important issues
forward I'm not able to contribute my
time to those issues because I have to
comply with the rules and regulations as
they pertain to
91a um I just want to give some
illustrative examples to say that the
right to no requests that we are
receiving do not have anything about
learning more about what the business of
government is doing these right to no
requests are asking about how people are
talking about them so any and all email
correspondents from or to the town
manager or select board that has my name
that has my name in conjunction with the
agenda that has my name in conjunction
with the documents my name in
conjunction with an attorney or any
other that was like one example a second
example of the same person giv the same
right to no request is that in today in
isolation or in Combined was my name
ever used in an email again these are
not illustrative examples of getting to
to know the business of government or
understanding how the workings of the
government is happening I as a general
rule have a deep appreciation for the
Freedom of Information Act or as we call
it the right to know act I'm an advocate
of government transparency and deeply
believe that residents should have
access to the government's records in my
time as Town manager we've gone above
and beyond to make sure that we are as
transparent as we possibly can be all of
our meetings are recorded we produce
minutes um our Board of Selectmen agenda
packets or over 100 Pages often times so
it's not that I want to minimize the
amount of transparency we have but I
would like to see how we could curtail
how these um requests are being
weaponized the 41 remaining qu requests
of the 70 were from two other people and
in those requests all they did was
riddle um and
call um my staff violent and egregious
allegations and violent names um it
creates a truly toxic work environment
from the outside coming in and again I
don't think that that is what the right
to no request is meant to do the right
to no request should be us presenting um
the documents I personally and my team
personally would rather us not have to
do the right to no request because we
feel like we have a more open dialogue
and we can give people the documents
that they want if it was more of a given
taken not and the right to no request my
sense can I just ask you to sum up
please my sense is when you get to the
right to no request you have to comply
with 91a specifically but if you can
have a conversation with people and get
them the documents in a different way
you end up having a better relationship
with your constituents so for me I think
that um I'd like to see us take
seriously the $25 rule I would actually
like to see you bring down the number of
hours that you require I think it's five
hours and then it's $25 because again
we're spending so much time on these
request and people are just weaponizing
them and attacking and name calling and
not getting transparency and not getting
down to the business of government all
right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very
much uh next I'm going to call on JD
lavalier from the uh AG's
office morning morning Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee I'll
I'll be quick um my name is is J Lali I
have the pleasure of serving the people
of New Hampshire as a senior Assistant
Attorney General up at the AG's office
um Department of Justice is thankful for
the opportunity to come here and testify
in support of HB uh 10002 Department
believes that the implementation of a
reasonable fee system for large right to
no requests supports the spirit and
purpose of the right to no law and our
state's constitutional principle of
reasonable public access to governmental
records how does a fee structure do this
a reasonable fee system can facilitate
conversations between State agencies
state public bodies and requesters uh
sort of as you just heard the last
commentator talk about the need for
dialogue um a reasonable fee system can
create greater efficiency in the
processing and access uh to governmental
records and in the rare instance uh a
reasonable fee uh system can
disincentivize the rare but highly
problematic uh vexatious uh requests
that are only meant to burden or impede
governmental business
um I think we can all agree uh that a
strong system of public access to
governmental records is built on
communication and having uh a natural
opportunity such as this bill creates to
enhance uh that communication between a
requester and the government uh can
hopefully enhance the Public's
understanding of how its government
works uh whether it's a better
understanding of the burden uh a request
May impose or perhaps a more efficient
way to access the ultimate information
that is sought
uh implementing a reasonable fee system
can also lead to Greater efficiency uh
and you sort of just heard a great case
a compelling case for efficiency
supporting the fundamental purpose of
the right to no law which is the public
access to governmental records uh by
creating an opportunity to uh discuss
requests it's the department of
Justice's hope and belief that not only
individual requesters will receive a
more timely response uh but the public
at large will be better served because
the state will be able to handle an
increased number of requests uh you're
all aware we're all aware uh our resour
resources are finite uh and especially
the most precious resource of all time
uh this bill helps address that however
uh not by creating more time but by
implementing a system in which time can
be valued and used most efficiently and
then last um though the department
believes the vast majority of requests
uh do not fall into this category youve
heard uh some officials uh talk about
the occasion where state agencies or or
municipalities or public bodies receive
vexatious requests that are incredibly
burdensome and require significant
resources tying those up and preventing
them uh from being used to uh for other
public purposes to serve the people of
New Hampshire uh so uh the department uh
supports the incentive structure created
by this bill overall we believe it
strikes an appropriate balance uh and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
here to questions for this witness yes
representative Smith
thank you very here I am here I
am um good morning thank you very much
for for being here I have a question and
I probably should know the answer but I
don't so can you help me
out is there any language in the
legislation that created the Ombudsman
to deal with right to know issues in
which a public agent
a town for example the town of sunap for
example could go to the
edsman to in some legal way Express
concern about the requests that had come
in thank you very much representative
ma'am I uh I am not sure that that
exists there's not language that I've
seen uh in the new language regarding
the EMB budsman that that uh would offer
that Avenue thank you yes representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question I'm a little concerned because
you used the term problematic
requests that bothers me um who
determines that it's problematic and
does someone I believe it's my
understanding that
everyone has the right to utilize the
right to know so I'm a little concerned
about calling
something problematic problematic to the
town because it takes more
time that person has as much right as
anyone else so I'm a little concerned
that you use the term problematic and
this would help with
problematic things because as I say
everybody it's my understanding has the
right to utilize the right to know
certainly representative thank you for
the question or or the comment um
to the extent that I I use the ambiguous
term problematic what I I probably
should have used was more vexatious sort
of going back to the previous comments
that you've heard about weaponization so
a a right to no request the intent
of the intent being only to uh impede
governmental business now I I completely
understand ma' uh you know intent is
extremely difficult to sus out and so I
I would note uh you know it's the
Department's uh view that everybody
should be able to make a right to no
request we certainly do not want to uh
uh come off of saying oh you know this
is a problematic request so therefore it
doesn't need need to be dealt with or
something of that nature all right other
questions yes representative Alexander
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you for indulging me um I previously
asked a question about the difference
between May and shall how would the um
AG's office deal with this sort of
ability for the town to charge for some
but not others and really not having a
conrete policy either way and how that
could be considered discrimination
depending on what their policy is set up
and who they who they charge and who
they decide not to charge uh certainly
representative thank you for the
question uh I think you've already heard
and and had some back and forth earlier
today about um you know potential
amendments or or thoughts I I think the
Department's position at this point in
time is uh that we would defer to the
policy decisions of the legislature um I
would just offer you know the the
Freedom of Information Act which I'm
sure U the ACLU and and many other
requesters are very familiar with has a
waver system uh so it's not a um I I
would offer that there's sort of a
greater Clarity in when is uh when there
will or won't be a charge and uh the OM
the Office of Management budget at the
federal level has you know published a
fee schedule so it's not um there's not
a lack of clarity I guess I would
offer other questions thank you very
much thank you sir next I'm going to
call on Amanda pal
please good morning good morning my name
is Amanda pal I'm the assistant City
attorney in in the city of Kean we the
city of Keane are in support of this
bill I wanted to quickly run through
some amendments we would like to see if
possible since the language is being
considered um in the bill there is a
section with added language concerning
inspection or delivery without copying
this is under section 4
d the added language is unless time to
make the records available exceeds 10
hours I'd like to talk about the
language that's not in bold there was a
case in 2017 Taylor
vs55 that helped clarify the first part
of that sentence inspection or delivery
without copying um the way that this
comes off on its face is that both
inspection and delivery would be without
copying but the court clarified we're
not sending out Originals delivery is
definitely going to be a copy so we
would just like to propose that we
invert those phrases to say for the
inspection without copying or delivery
of governmental records um what the
court had considered was the concept of
the cost of copying records in
electronic
format uh of course inspection without
copying would be without cost at the
time if there's a copy fee whereas
copying even in electronic format had a
copy fee so just like to tune that up um
since we're there then in looking at the
last provision that's going to be new
language in Section
8 we also thought it would be helpful to
clarify what the 10 hour is we wanted to
propose that the clause in excess of 10
hours is added so that the phrase is for
the employee time in excess of 10 hours
it's my understanding the intent is not
to charge for you know if it's a 12
hour cost or time that you charge for 12
it's just the two on top of the 10 so um
over in Keen uh our staff and I adore
them for it looks at rsas pretty closely
tries to stick with the words very
helpful to me um but therefore I want to
take an opportunity to clarify the
language a little bit um and also in
light of that the second sentence in
that section Section 8 um would like it
to say hourly cost shall not exceed $25
per hour and no hourly costs shall be
charged for requests under 10 so just
adding the word hourly for those two
mentions to be
consistent So speaking more generally
the city is in support of this bill
particularly with those amendments I
referenced uh the goal of the bill as we
understand it is for protection of our
Municipal staff um our time our taxpayer
funding the law currently prohibits any
cost for our staff time only allows for
copy
charges um and we found that staff time
really is the largest impact of the work
required for the right to no law um and
coming from the city of Kean even with
this back stop the vast majority of our
requests do not take 10 hours I did um a
rudimentary survey of our requests and
and speaking to our clerk's office on
average it's two to three hours of
request um and then the two years I've
been with the city I've worked with the
keing police requests um and I've only
ever seen one that's been more than 10
hours at all so so can I just ask you to
wrap up for sure thank you so our
position is that this bill would not
dtor right to no requests it would serve
as a very good protection of uh City
staff time taxpayer funding particularly
in uh smaller towns who who may need to
spend more time great thank you
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you uh Al brand brandano
please my name is Alber andano I'm from
Kensington New Hampshire and I'm
speaking in opposition to this
bill I want to read article 38 of the
Constitution to you it's called social
uh virtues but Artic in in calculated
but just a small part of it here it says
the people ought therefore to have a
particular regard to all those
principles in the choice of the offices
and representatives and they have a
right to require of the lawgivers and
the magistrates an exact and constant
observance of them in the formation and
execution of the laws
necessary for the good administration of
government you're taxing if this goes
through our enumerated rights the rights
that are given to us in the
Constitution you're going to tax
us it it's it's you know regardless if
you're Republican Democrat or
independent doesn't matter we need to go
back to
this sometimes the rsas a repugnant to
the Constitution and this case it is we
surely can't charge people for the right
to know and what really troubles me is
we have a line item in town budgets for
insurance for police for
attorneys put a line item in if this is
a problem in a town put a line item in
and have the town vote on it and appoint
somebody that does this on especially
the bigger towns that need this but you
cannot charge a citizen under this
constitution are we we we might as well
not even have
it and last for me it when there the
discussion about people outside of being
a citizen in New Hampshire you know
maybe there is something for that but
not for the people in New
Hampshire and I will take any questions
questions for this
witness thank you very much sir thank
you uh Brenda golden hesy
please good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
micophone oh
sorry good morning um my name is Brenda
golden hesy I work with the office of
professional life insurance
certification
uh I am agency counsel there um the
office does not take a position on this
bill but um I would like to offer some
insight on what part of my job is a
substantial part of my job in fact um I
handle the majority of the 91a requests
that come into the office um we get on
average one request a day um a lot of
times more than that some of them are
misdirected they're not write to no
requests at all others just require
simple answers
um but a lot of them are for commercial
purposes people requesting mailing lists
requesting um addresses um uh emails to
lenses so that they can send them um
solicitations for continuing education
or or other um reasons um we don't have
to compile lists if we don't already
keep them in that Ma manner um according
to
91847 um and there are a lot of requests
for uh non-public items such as um
investigations that um are exempt from
public
disclosure um on average a right to no
request a simple one would probably take
between two to five hours um three hours
would probably be spent by board
Administration to try to locate and
gather the information and probably uh
another two hours
um of my time um to check to make sure
that no private information was being
disclosed and to do redactions and so
forth um now a board administrator makes
anywhere between uh $25 and $30 an hour
um I make upwards of $45 an hour so in
salary alone for a very simple request
we're probably talking about
$165 um not including benefits and
overhead and these costs are not paid by
the tax ta payers they actually paid by
the lenses board administrators and I
had started on work um and spent several
hours um the request was modified to
only require um information from Medical
Dental mental health and nursing and
Chiropractic uh later the request was
again modified the requestor wanted to
see videos of any public hearings you
know can I just ask you to wrap up man'
please certainly um so I think that a
lot of times that the the
um the people think that it's a matter
of pushing a button or just getting some
quick information to fulfill these
requests we can't just have people come
into the offices in these case and make
copies or examine items because they're
not isolated from items that have
personal information on it um so in in
this case um again these are for
commercial purposes and somebody wants
this information to make and is making a
lot of money from this information and
um I think that um if if anything to
charge something in these cases um might
deter some of the larger commercial
requests all right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you uh Harrison Thorp
please
good morning uh this is all about right
to know and I've been living the right
to know nightmare for about 8 10 months
uh basically on this bill right here the
one thing I have a problem with is
saying that town or city can come back
with a suggestion now does that mean
that the that suggestion is the final
amount of what is going to be allowed to
be given as per your right to no request
because if that's mandated then that's
weakening the law because you call for
one thing and they says well you can't
have this but you can have that that's
my suggestion do you have to take it and
if you have to take it that's that's a
that's a
nonstarter uh also uh I want I need an
addendum into this bill that says
citizen means citizen of the United
States or citizen of the world world
because as a citizen of Maine that
covers the city of Rochester and has one
you know 10 15 20 awards from the New
Hampshire press Association that is
recognized and uh business of the year
in
2021 and a community service award which
I wouldn't have been able to get without
having right to no ability uh from the
New Hampshire press Association I would
never have done it that was about a
flawed land deal by the city of
Rochester for a third fire station that
the purchase and sale agreement had no
hold harmless agreement on the city of
Rochester the city council voted down
the land purchase so the city council
voted down the land purchase they went
into a non- meeting with the attorney
they came back a half hour later and
they approved the purchase because they
were under threat of a lawsuit for
breaking a purchase and sale agreement
so I'm a citizen of Maine I covered this
Rochester voice I cover the city of
Rochester every single day and on April
12th the City attorney sent me an email
saying we have discovered that you 30
hours of time preparing for my uh on
budman's uh because I I did a right to
no request to the on buzzman I spent 30
hours he ended up not even making a
decision he said it was not in his
jurisdiction to determine whether
citizen citizen of New Hampshire or
citizen of has to be a citizen of New
Hampshire
so when he did that now the city of
Rochester is
appealing that to the Judiciary so I'm
asking the legislature to determine that
the citizen means citizen of the United
States because the city of Rochester is
looking to have the Judiciary determine
what citizen means whether means citizen
of New Hampshire or citizen of the
United States all right thank you very
much sir questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next
um uh Katherine coko
please good morning members of the
Judiciary Committee my name is Katherine
coko I am the president of right to know
New Hampshire we are an all volunteer
citizen-based group um spanning the
entire state that advocates for
transparency in government um I will try
to keep my points to a number of things
that I actually have not heard raised
today so I hope they will be of interest
to you um the first is uh the concern
that this bill first and foremost is
based on a need that has been defined
only anecdotally at best our
organization itself had a member who
volunteered to solicit input about the
size of this issue
um it's been referred to as
weaponization uh problematic other terms
that we've heard the response that she
received from nhma and uh stated that
large requests are infrequent the input
that she got from other communities was
very limited the sponsor itself has said
there are very few examples of these
large requests um we do know that
sizable requests tend to occur as the
result of commercial requests from data
Gathering entities rather from
individuals or the Bad actors that we
are hearing about some of those today
but without a well-defined need this
bill imposes an unreasonable restriction
on New Hampshire's only operational
protection of citizen access to
transparent government if this bill is
not deemed itl which is what we would
like to see it should at least require
further study to quantify the actual
problem before attempting to impose the
statutory solution more importantly the
mechanism that is proposed by this bill
is entirely unnecessary voluminous
requests regardless of source are and
always will be subject to the standard
that they be reasonably described this
standard was most recently addressed in
the 2022 case of kin versus nasua there
is a plethora of state and federal case
law that has already determined what
kind of request is reasonable and how a
public body May Place reasonable
restrictions on a right to no request to
ensure that it is not unreasonably
burdensome it is largely contextual and
it requires an understanding of the law
and is not as simple as the language
that is put forward the public body can
also apply the standard of
reasonableness to its own search for
documents and Define what thinks is a
reasonable search the case law defining
that reasonableness standard includes
American oversight versus the US EPA
Freedom watch Inc versus Department of
State Dale Versus Internal Revenue
Service muckrock LLC versus the CIA and
ATV watch versus the New Hampshire
Department of
Transportation in Rel finally in
relation to reasonableness public bodies
also have considerable leeway to set
reasonable timelines on the response
that they give and that has also been
upheld in case law including in my own
case person versus the town of Milford
it can be difficult for communities to
understand those parameters and some may
think that this is a simple solution um
but we believe the real issue here is
Education and Training of public bodies
as an example after discussing these
kinds of requests with my own Community
it became very clear that one voluminous
requests tend to come routinely from
those commercial entities that have been
previously mentioned and two that a
thorough understanding of what the
community is and is not required to
provide and an internal policy on
dealing with those have been incredibly
effective in my hometown in managing
those requests and understanding that
reasonableness standard is key to that
can I ask you to just sum up please
you're you're at the three minute Mark
we would like to work with public bodies
and nhma to make sure that those who
receive these requests understand that
standard I have a number of points here
about it being incredibly important to
understand that in you have written
testimony you may certainly do submit
that but uh I you're you're really at
over your time limit now is the advocate
and I will then at and wrap up saying
this bill is bad for public interest
it's bad for communities and instead
communities should be working to
understand the right to no law trained
on the public um on right to know and
ensure that they're properly equipped to
understand the reasonableness standard
and I will add particularly given the
presence of the AG's office here that
another step forward be would be
updating the AG's 2015 memo to reflect
the most recent case law which has been
repeatedly requested by our group and
other agencies and has not been done all
right questions for this week yes Mr
chair yeah uh yes uh represent D Lorenzo
please thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm just a
little curious what was your thought
when we heard the Assistant Attorney
General um say that he's in favor of the
Bill thank you representative D Lorenzo
I I was um probably not surprised but I
am very concerned that there is numerous
case law that has impacted how
communities respond to this that um
current memo actually has a reference to
the citizen issue that has repeatedly
come up and I will reference in another
upcoming bill um that clarify some of
that and um feel that that really needs
to be the priority is understanding what
the current situation is rather than
instituting a fee structure
representative Smith thank you could you
please submit your written testimony to
us um if you could get copies to us and
that's a much better way to give us
complicated information than to speed
read thank you I I will I tried to keep
the bullets but I will synthesize it
thank you great thank you other
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to uh call on MAR uh
Marty Moy uh Moy
please Marty
Moy all right I don't see Mr Mobley here
all right next I will uh call on uh
Brendan mcade
please I do have some written testimony
but I have additional thoughts on thank
you so my name is Brendan McCade I am a
resident of Manchester I am the
publisher of the New Hampshire union
leader and I am the President of the New
Hampshire press Association uh the New
Hampshire press Association is strongly
opposed to this bill um and a few of my
thoughts number one um I'm disturbed by
the notion I feel you all should be
disturbed too that we keep hearing which
is geez these citizens that want to know
what we're doing are really annoying
it'd be great if we could do something
about that um we keep hearing about out
of state and Commercial interests uh
that may be a problem that needs to be
dealt with but this bill doesn't deal
with that this bill creates a situation
for
everyone putting in right to no requests
of which our paper puts in a lot and our
membership uh including Harrison uh put
in a lot too um I would caution if you
do attempt to address the outof state
interest think of entities like Mr har
person who are out of state but covering
New Hampshire the Boston Globe is
another example um and we had someone
from Keen here the students at Keen
State also had a right to know issue a
couple years ago for which they won an
award they are likely out of state some
of them because they're students and
they're in state and they're studying
and they're trying to figure out how
government works so I would caution you
against anything blanket on out of state
or commercial um and please don't do
commercial because that would really hit
our media um the fees that you put into
place in this law will do nothing for
those big commercial operators they will
laugh at paying 250 bucks for the
information they want if they can get
it um there are problems now as many of
you know with exceptions under 91a and a
lot of entities just don't want to
provide stuff so um you know we've we've
had a lot of talk about weaponizing of
91a here uh this bill provides a very
potent weapon to any agency that's
currently unresponsive and I would
encourage you not to give them
that thank you questions for this
witness yes representative Smith thank
you Mr McQuade
um when I came to the legislature The
Press Room was full and now it's empty
and we have very few ways of getting out
to the public information about what we
do here I'm thinking I live on the Sea
Coast and I'm thinking in fact that the
newspapers and the Sea Coast not only
don't have reporters here but they're
owned by an outof State entity they're
no longer owned by anyone in the state
does that mean that if a right to our
request came
in from one of those members of the
fourth estate that they would be
considered out of state and therefore
not relevant that's why I say if you're
if you're going to look at anything
addressing out of state or commercial
operations to consider that in any
legislation that you might put forward
thank you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you um and I'm now I'm G to call
on H natch graay
please
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm n Grace with the municipal
Association we do support this bill um
I've handed out and I also uploaded
earlier this morning um a copy of uh
written testimony um really the second
page uh is the second piece of paper is
the relevant one it contains our survey
results um one of the questions that we
had as the conversation evolved over the
course of the summer and fall was well
what are large requests what are average
requests let's see what our members
think we had about 70 members respond uh
and the way they defined average request
in terms of time inputed to respond was
a maximum of 5 hours with a mean and a
median of 1 hour and two hours um and I
think this is some important data that
you can review later at your at your
leisure uh that really demonstrates the
fear of of uh hurting the average
citizen is misplaced with this
legislation um I think the 10hour um
10hour limit uh gives a good buffer
between what what we saw our members
report versus what actually
happens um there were we've heard a lot
of complaints today about uh citizens
getting the wrong stuff um I think that
section e that's proposed in this
legislation is very important um it
really incentivizes and creates the
opportunity for conversation to occur
between between the government and the
citizen um so we can be sure the
citizens are getting what they actually
want and not what they don't want um and
I think that really helps uh Define the
need of of this legislation that's in
front of you
today um there were a couple questions
about how exactly uh
Roman uh the last paragraph here would
be interpreted um our interpretation was
that it's a a local option um so that it
would be a a set fee um at your
municipality so if someone came in for a
request that took 12 hours they could
only be charged for two of those hours
um and those two hours would be whatever
that locally adopted fee is up to the
statutory amount of $25 so it may be the
case that your community wants a minimum
wage it may be the case that your um
Community doesn't want a fee it may be
the case they want $25 an hour if the
request takes uh that amount of time
they would get that charge um that way
we don't have any local officials in
inquiring into the purpose of your
request because really our our only job
is to uh make sure you get what you want
so so can I just interrupt just for one
second Mr Grace am I understanding it
correctly then from from what you just
said that um there was a a question
raised earlier about that there's some I
mean the the way the the language of the
bill is now drafted it could be read to
say that if the request is over 10 hours
then you can charge for the whole in
other words if it's a 12h hour request
you can charge for the whole 12 hours
what you're saying is you would have no
you you would have no problem if it said
and if it's over 10 hours you can only
charge for the excess correct and that
was my original understanding um I'm
glad that the city of Keane brought that
up um we do not want to charge for 10
hours or less okay um for uh two other
quick points um uh a number of
individuals have brought up the question
of citizen in the
definition um that's contained in 91 A4
Roman 1 um that isn't touched by this
bill um at the risk of incurring some
unhappiness behind me um I do want to
point out that house bill 1696 which is
also scheduled uh here
today uh deals with that section so that
may be the appro appropriate Bill to
deal with that section on just so
there's no overlapping or
confusion um and five I don't believe
anyone mentioned this today um but um
there is in the legislation in front of
you a uh provision that for these large
requests the government has to provide
an estimate of the time as well as the
cost which means they have to account
for their time accurately um that's kind
of inherently built in there and it
protects citizens from surprised bills
as I understand it the um Prime sponsor
has handed out an amendment to all of
you um that clarifies that if someone is
concerned about how much time it's
taking to get their records back or how
much that cost is they can appeal to the
right to no I'm spudman and obviously uh
a check to make sure that everyone's uh
following the law doing it fairly um and
everything is being applied equally is
very important because we want to make
sure that citizens are getting what
they're entitled to uh and fairly I'm
happy to take any questions questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you well I'm
sorry representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question my concern
about giving a Time on how long it's
going to
take how long it takes me to do
something could be very different than
how long it takes you to do something
and and if I don't like
you I may take a longer period of time I
have a problem with that because as some
of you here know we've had big problems
in different towns with people who don't
like people and things that they do so
that concerns me because you are trying
to say that everybody does something at
the
same in the same amount of time
so well I I think if you look at the the
second page uh the second sheet of paper
of my handout um you'll see that I
provided you a graph of the different
responses for the maximum amount of time
it took to respond to the average
request with the maximum being 5 hours
many municipalities were quicker than
that I think um that this is important
data to look at because even if there is
a personality conflict having a buffer
between what the data shows is the
maximum and what
uh the committee decides is an
appropriate hour limit um will help
ensure that if it goes P if if a request
comes in that's you know pretty basic
request and it goes past that time that
when that person sees that estimate and
they realize hey wait a minute I think
that somebody hates me they can go to
the right to Noom budsman ask for that
to be reviewed and the right to OMS
buman would logically say that's an
reasonable amount of time um and I think
that's yep go
ahead that doesn't bother me as much and
going to the on budsman is a wonderful
idea but not everybody has the time to
go to the on
budsman I think it's a great thing for
91a what concerns me the most is you're
trying to make a judgment on how long it
takes you as opposed to me or as opposed
to her to do the same thing and I don't
think we can we can do that you know I
mean it's based on if you know what
you're looking for it your knowledge of
it and how fast you can get it and your
almost based on your personality whether
you tend to go or not go so that's my
concern is trying to put ours and I
understand I and I think it's great to
have you know um
request but you're still trying to put
judging everyone doing something at the
same time is there is there a qu is
there a question here okay all right
representative
Manos thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um in your view are
your members are the towns and cities
entitled to invoke the EMB budsman and
if so do they do that and what's your
experience with
that so my understanding the law is
currently written is that the cities and
towns are not able to go to the
Ombudsman to ask to review a request
that comes in now I may be speaking out
of turn but I understand then the other
side of the wall they may or may not be
considering an amendment to a bill that
would enable
that other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much I don't
have any other uh pink cards is there
anyone else who wishes to speak on House
Bill
102 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 102 and I know
that we are running quite late uh for
which I'm sorry but uh not much I can do
about it I'm now going to open the
hearing on House Bill
and is there anyone here who would like
to introduce that bill uh representative
Edwards
representative hmon I don't see here Mr
chair I can if yeah yeah would you mind
uh yeah give me one second
sure thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Joe Alexander I represent Hillsboro
District 29 town of gtown um out of
courtesy to the members that introduce
this legislation I'd like to introduce
this legislation and I will be taking
questions thank you thank you all right
uh I'm gonna Now call on uh Joanne
archal please Janan I'm sorry Janan
archal
sorry thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee
my name is Janan archal I'm the director
of policy and government Affairs for on
Sky Community Services we are one of the
area agencies that Services individuals
with developmental disabilities and
acquired brain disorders were located in
the Sea Coast I became interested in
this um legislation based on feedback
that I had from our families and
individuals who told me that they were
submitting right to no requests and were
not able to get documents that were in
draft format and that could last um
quite a while I asked them um I it's
worth noting that I did try to resolve
this before coming before you um by
making phone calls and talking with a
number of of entities trying to figure
out what exactly the law was um so the
feedback that I received from the
families was we cannot get the draft
documents and and these items could stay
in draft for months maybe forever and so
the families weren't able to obtain that
information um when I started calling
around to different people including the
Ombudsman I was referred to um section
9182 which says the meeting shall not
include circulation of draft
documents so I think some entities and I
also TR did try to find out whether it
was just one agency one school that was
had a misunderstanding of the law but it
seemed to be sort of a pervasive
misunderstanding of what documents were
subject to the right to know then when I
spoke with the Ombudsman he referred me
to 91a section 5 exemptions which said
that preliminary drafts no notes
memoranda Etc if they have been
circulated to a quorum that they were
subject to the right to know law so a
little bit of um confusion there so I
have come before you to ask if there's
anything that you can do to just Define
what is subject to the 91a law are draft
subject to it is is there a Sunset date
so just to clear up the confusion that
exists from boots on the ground um I've
had a lot of Spirited discussions over
this issue and a lot of different
opinions have sort of come
forward questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank
you uh Susan price Susan Rice please I'm
sorry turn on the mic
please just press the press the button
it the rid there you go thank you sorry
about that um SU rice 15910 Rod Road
Rochester New Hampshire um I do
appreciate the comments that I just
heard from um this fellow um Parson and
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak um I would just
like a little clarification as to what a
preliminary draft actually means um
versus um my my world basically centered
around planning boards and Technical
Review Committee reports um what
distinguishes a preliminary draft why is
it limited to a preliminary draft versus
something that goes beyond a preliminary
draft and then further as I'm reading
this um what is the difference between a
preliminary draft in materials and then
when it goes on further for copying um
it gives this whole list but it doesn't
go one step further and say that copying
of preliminary drafts circulated to a
quum can be made
um so those were just some of my
preliminary questions um in in reading
this thank you for your time thank you
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much man' next Katherine
coko thank you um again I represent
right to know New Hampshire um we are
neutral on this bill I do um want to
make a suggestion um that we did have
some concerns from the group about the
um just the language that we take out
the information that is in italics place
it under other um after under under
Source other sources in parentheses and
say including preliminary drafts
circulated to a quorum or majority of
the public body this exemption is
already covered this is already covered
in the exemption section of the law um
so we support there being a clar
verification because it is routinely a
problem I have run into it in in my
hometown um they were routinely
withholding all drafts of anything until
I came along and pointed out that those
had to be provided once they'd been
circulated to a quorum of the board and
now the town has changed their policy on
that so I appreciate personally the
clarification that the sponsor is trying
to get our concern was that the way it
was worded it might look like everything
needed to be a draft or some other thing
that had been circulated fully if they
were a material a tape or another source
so we just want to make sure that's very
clear all right questions for this
witness yes representative Alexander
thank you um thank you for taking my
question did you so so from what I'm
understanding you you didn't run into
any problems when you brought it up to
your town I ran into a number of um
within the town issues I believe they
then asked for clarification from
nhma um and town legal council and they
were advised that yes under the
exemption if a material had been
circulated to a Corum of the board they
had to turn it over they were not doing
that until then okay so it it was
resolved under the current law it was
okay thank but it had to go outside I
you know beyond the town right other
questions for this
witness yes oh I'm sorry representative
trip
yes um thank you for taking my question
uh have you had experienced any issues
with the towns uh retaining copies of
draft
documents we have uh routinely gotten
questioned about this particular issue
where there somebody will say well this
is being withheld because of the draft
exemption and we routinely answer that
question with once it's been circulated
to a quorum of the board or the public
body then they have to turn it over so
yes beyond my personal experience thank
you other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much ma'am uh
I don't have any other pink cards is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
1069 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1069 um and I'm going to open the
1696 um and Mr chair I believe
representative bigford was here and then
he left
oh yeah yeah sure sure yeah we'll take a
yeah let's take a let's take a five
minute recess
please yes sure yes
please
so
yeah
all right all right I'm going to uh
reconvene uh the Judiciary Committee uh
and we now have we're going to open the
hearing on House Bill
1696 and I'm going to recognize uh
representative David Bickford this Prime
sponsor thank you Mr chair uh again my
name is David Bickford from new dorham
and I also represent uh Middleton and
I'm here today to introduce HB
1696 and I passed out a paper like this
you to uh I hope you all have
it uh
no don't
oh this
is this is a
um Announcement by our town of New
Durham after we had a class put on by
the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and the municipal
Association said us we were not to do
electronic copies to anyone any longer
we've been doing it for some
time um and so they put up this notice
and I'll on October 30th I I'll read it
out it's short based on the advice of
the New Hampshire Municipal
Association legal
council the town of New Durham will no
longer provide electronic copies of
documents requested under provisions of
New Hampshire RSA
91a document uh may be reviewed at the
Town Hall Once the request has been
completed copies can be made and per
page fees will be
charged um and so that's why I brought
this bill to you because this is going
on as you heard recently in Rochester
also and a number of other communities
have class doing electronics and it's
ridiculous my
estimation
um I don't
think the New Hampshire Municipal
Association possibly saw the decision of
green uh versus school administrative
unit number
55 and that if you go to
page six or even just seven will
concluded
says in some under all circumstances we
conclude that the plaintiff is entitled
to the requested documents in electronic
format furthermore producing electronic
documents is often more efficient and
coste effective than producing them in
paper
form providing electronic records can be
cheaper and easier for the public body
than paper
records
now it was interesting because you and
I'm sorry I didn't have extra copies of
this it's just seven pag time times too
many all right uh I I one I have one
copy here yeah and I have only one
more oh thank you thank you
um do it
electronic uh it was interesting how
they went back inste of the statute is
ambiguous on both parties and said and
uh we're both reasonable so we therefore
look to the purpose of the right to no
law which is to increase public access
to all public documents and governmental
proceedings and to provide the utmost
information to the public about what its
government is up to so my bill even
though I didn't actually find out about
this until after I fil my bill is to
codify this here and if you folks see
anything a way to do it better um that's
fine and the most the most important
thing is your chairman is one of the
signatories to this
[Laughter]
decision so I thank you very much Judge
Lynn for your good
work and uh I don't know if I need to
say any
more uh questions yes representative
Perez thank you for taking my question I
have received electronic documents from
my town but they charged me the exact
same as if I had gotten them paper
that's not legal that's my understanding
to be charging you except for paper
copies it says I have been charged and
they quoted an RSA saying that they
could charge me for copies and that's
fine they can charge me for copies I
understand that but I received them
electronically and got Char charged I
believe there is a bill coming forward
that will stop that from happening but
well if you don't you can do an
amendment because we because is Mr
Harrison no Thor Mr Thor had said and
another fellow said too it's so
important for us to get the information
the newspapers need the information keep
us informed that's critically important
otherwise we lose our democracy and
charging for electronic like paper yeah
perhaps yeah we've always done it
through the tax dollars and it's because
it's about it's about government yeah
it's about all of us and so when I read
a news article whether it be the union
leader or any other
and they've gotten their information
from the town or school district U it's
for all of us to be informed
about that's
Civics 101 other qu yes represent Smith
um thank you um Mr chair for recognizing
me um representative bigford knowing um
that your legislative Roots Began in
this Committee in
1997 um your judge is important to me do
you see any reason that the chair of
this committee uh would have to recuse
himself from voting on this since his
role in the judicial branch has been
noted I I don't see a conflict of
interest I don't I doubt he's going to
make any money on
[Laughter]
this other questions for this witness
yes representative
Andre thank than you Mr chair uh M
representative bigford did you go to the
AG's office with this and ask him if it
a bill was
necessary ex I didn't quite understand
that okay did all right you there was a
word I missed I'm sorry
yeah sometimes I don't word things
correctly excuse me okay did you take
this the bill you mean the bill to the
AG's office and ask them if it was
necessary
I mean to me the municipal Association
just because the illegal counsel said
something like this was necessary is it
does it actually have to be or just is
there a misunderstanding because I'll
tell you my school district I send them
an email and they just send me stuff
electronically they've been doing it for
years so I don't understand what the
issue is with this I I agree with I have
not been to the Attorney General's
office because I just felt it was
important to get it in the statute so
didn't get misinterpreted because it
looks to me like they're just looking at
the Statue and not doing the is it
called shepherding or in uhing shepher
ising thank
you
um does that that I ask your question I
says well I'm I'm here I can make a
change
here yes uh representative D Lorenzo and
then representative Perez okay thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question representative bfid yeah you
know I'm looking at this notice that you
passed out um and it says say I don't
want to read the whole thing to you but
on the advice of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association legal council I
mean is that that doesn't look official
to me why wouldn't the nhma legal
council write the notice rather than
have it quoted by the municipality do
you understand what I mean you
understand what I'm saying I well kind
of this is the selectman put this up
they there was I think I know one
selectman was there sitting by behind me
and I went to the same class so I heard
the same thing and so immediately oh my
gosh we got to shut that down then and I
I think the logic was well you know
there's machines out there that create
requests and we can't have that and so
what my bill does it's it's just allows
the town to do it it's it's a Meg and
you'll see in if you get the decision
they talk a lot about May in here but
I'm
saying the towns want to be able to just
do this and send out information out
they don't want to have to have somebody
come in and then copy it and say have a
nice day and that stuff it's just time
consuming and awkward um now we have one
selectman he lives half the time in
another
state and he gets all his stuff
electronically from the town but Mr
Harrison here he wants he has to come to
the town hall and get it that I I
consider that ridiculous the same
information
so just to follow up personally if I
were a citizen of that town I would I
would really U question leg the
legitimacy of this um issue right here
legitimacy yes I think it's very legi
they said we have been advised okay by
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
not to I did talk to the slman
afterwards that put it up okay and told
him about it and I said well and and
said that I was I say I intend to put a
bill in to uh what I that have correct
this okay all right well thank you all
right representative Perez thank you
thank you for taking my question would
you have would you be all right with
adding at no charge to this or putting
in the language that they can't charge
for electronically sending something I
very much would like it actually but
it's a matter of you know what you can
pull off yeah right because you know I I
was charged yeah yeah I think it's
critically important to have information
out of dips thanks representative manx
thank you um if records if specific
records that are requested are still in
paper format this would not mandate or
would it mandate that the that the town
convert it to electronic and then send
it out or can they still choose to use
the paper rope they can still choose to
use the paper rope yeah with my bill
anyway but but I but I would welcome
that all right other questions yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question um I'm I just thought
of like maybe an unintended consequence
of requiring that it has to be
electronic at all times I see like the
future and maybe represented being or
represent Kenny can attest to this the
future of AI and how you can start
creating prompts and just sending
arbitrary right to no requests over and
over and over again from a computer just
sending it
in what's what's to stop somebody from
just sending in repeated electronic
requests and requiring it has to be an
electronic format well for one thing the
Bill's not written that we just
discussed that with representative Manis
the bill is not okay demanding you can
ignore them or you can say do the FED
day thing say Well we'd like to see you
come in we'd like to see some K you can
do whatever you want but you're not
required to send it out to the AI okay
okay yeah you you'll see you'll see it's
if you read the bill you'll see the what
I'm talking about there all right thank
you other questions for this witness you
know one just one I just have it one
it's sort of a question and a comment my
I'm going back now it's it's hard to
believe that it's been four years since
I left the Judiciary but um I believe
that there is another SAU 55 taste that
I was the author of oh that right that
dealt with and I and I'm I'm I'm having
difficulty recollecting exactly but I
thought that one I think that one of the
issues there was
that it was I think the court said it
was okay for towns to use the paper
format in in some circumstances in order
to make sure that they had a proper
record that they had
responded um you know if and I as I say
I don't have a close Rec election of it
but I will look at it you know before we
before we EXA this bill just to to make
because I I mean I'm very speaking
personally I'm very much in favor of
this and I also agree with
representative Perez that it would be
good to have the you know making sure
you can't charge um but I did I I do
have I do want to go back and look at
that case because there was some issue
there about towns wanting to be able to
you know make sure that they had a
record that they properly responded so
that they wouldn't be accused of not
having responded correctly and I thought
that there was something in that case
dealing with it must have been when you
were much long younger that's right
that's right much sure I wasn't having
the senior moments that's
right all right uh yes represent Staples
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um the suggestion not
to charge for the electronic record
pertains to copies right not necessarily
the research or the administrative time
to collect that information is that
right yes thank you you do that's what
you do now we have been doing it that
way actually right along it's only it's
only when they put that class on and
insisted that we cannot be doing this
anymore and I stopped them in the tracks
I said what at the class and I said you
want to repeat that for me and uh so we
had quite a discussion on it and uh at
that point I lost but as you can see
because this is what came up
yeah thank you all right we'll win in
the end other questions for
representative Bickford yes
representative trip uh could you refresh
my memory on what the name of the case
was green yeah
Green it's yes green without the e on
the end it's G re n thank you first name
is Donna and S U uh
55 who's that oh okay do you want more
than that or it'll come right up on a
computer with that what you have all
right but I needed the search term
first yes oh you yeah you got Donna
green okay all right any other questions
for this witness thank you very much
representative pford thank you um next
I'm going to call on representative
Cliff Newton
please thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I said it all last bill so I
don't have to say it again this time all
right well that's no good we're going to
we're going to hold you in three minutes
it just makes
sense to get it in electronic format why
would you take 1,800 pages of electronic
format and transfer it into paper to
give it to somebody it doesn't what the
city used to do of Rochester they would
say do you want it on electronic format
or do you want it in paper form if if
you wanted in electronic format they
said we have thumb drives at $22.50 a
piece or you can provide a thumb drive
as long as it's brand new so you weren't
putting some kind of you know virus into
their computer and this just makes sense
the other Common Sense part is
electronic format is so much easier to
share if you have a group that basically
wants the same thing everyone doesn't
have to go down a city hall and ask for
the same thing you can say I'll share it
with you recently the uh County of of
straford we're all delegate members
we're building a new nursing home and I
tried to get information I tried to find
out how much have we got spent so far in
this nursing home and I got five
different answers and I could not get
the right answer and finally I had to
ask a write to no request and I asked
for documents in electronic format and I
got 54 documents some of them were 20 30
pages long it was so convenient to get
in an electronic format that you could
read and you could put in your own
categories instead of having to try to
do it with paper it just makes sense and
finally what I'll say is
uh when you get in electronic format
people like myself that need different
glasses to read and magnifying glasses
you can zoom The View you can make it so
you can understand it and I'll close
with this think green view a screen
Save the Planet save the trees go
electronic thank you questions for this
wi thank you very much
representative Harrison Thorp from the
Rochester voice
please
Mr um I mean people of a certain age
they remember back in school right
Elementary School passing
notes passing notes to each other do
they do that anymore no they don't so
Rochester supplied me with digital right
to no request very
quickly uh very efficiently within a
couple of days sometimes the same day
until April 12th when they all a sudden
arbitrarily said no more digital uh
delivery of right to no
requests because you're not a citizen of
New Hampshire so we've got to clear that
up I live a half a
mile from New Hampshire predominantly
covered 98 just so you'll know Mr Thorp
I there I have an amendment along with
representative Bickford that we're gonna
that I'm going to present when the when
the committee uh when we that that does
away with the the citizen thing thank
you just been I'm a proud Manor Maniac
sorry uh also
uh it's green as as Cliff said and uh
suddenly
Rochester is now not even given a
citizen of
Rochester digital they have to come in
and get it in paper form so that is
absolutely absurd and in the ma past few
months the New Hampshire Municipal
Association all of a sudden organically
started sprouting out going around from
town to town to town to town and saying
uh giving lectures giving whatever you
call it Forums on how to start making
private citizens come into the business
office and ask to view during regular
business hours which is a huge huge
hindrance on any private citizen let
alone a news entity like the Rochester
voice I mean we're talking about hours
and hours and when I did this as I told
you before I went into the DPW like
attorney o roor from Rochester told me
to do I sat in the chart i' like to view
some documents and the receptionist goes
what what are you talking about just
please email it so the receptionist
asked me to go back and send in my
request
digitally and then the attorney gets the
request and then they print up the stuff
and say you can come on in and get it
for
$3 uh and I just went in there and took
pictures of it because I know how to do
things
digitally and I just walked away I said
I don't want that pile of paper so
please digital makes sense all right
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir Susan Rice
please
Susan Rice 15910 Rod Road Rochester New
Hampshire um in the packet of stuff that
I had just received um that actually
that 91a request um and like most of the
requests and I'm not an abuser of the
91a requests it's only when I can't find
something um that I submit one I always
put on there that I prefer to receive it
via email or
electronically
um and up until about March or April of
this past year um that was pretty much
honored and very rarely did I have to go
into City Hall to pick something
up um and then all of a sudden it
changed and this request going through
it was all emails and it would have
saved myself
$488 had I been able to receive that
electronically in today's society the
ability to communicate electronically
and to understand and know what are what
is occurring is critical in our
government wasteful use of resources
such as paper Power Fuel and most and
the most precious commodity of all is
our time there is also one other factor
I may look perfectly normal to the
average person with no physical
impediments However
unfortunately I do suffer from being a
diabetic and I have a severe eye issue
being able to receive communication via
email or electronically is basically
invaluable to me no price tag can be
placed on a person's vision and the
ability to enhance the script to perhaps
change the font makes it much easier in
my day-to-day living and it also having
to take time out of my day I am a
business owner in downtown Rochester it
just adds one more thing that I have to
go and do that I could just open up my
email and have that there thank you for
taking my testimony thank you questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much uh Brendan mcade
please
hello members of the committee uh my
name is Brendan McQuade I'm a citizen of
Manchester uh and I am the publisher of
the New Hampshire union leader and
president of the New Hampshire press
Association um I'm here today because
the New Hampshire press Association is
in support of HB
1696 um for the basic reason of isn't it
obvious it's
2024 if something can be emailed email
it that's what we all want that's what
we all expect and I will just add to
everyone you know the the benefits of
emailing in
documents there's the benefits of of
emailing the documents in you know being
able to read them everything else for us
as a newspaper and for news
organizations when documents can be
gotten electronically especially larger
documents or documents that are spread
sheets and things like that you can
search the data you can manipulate the
data and you can figure out what's going
on um as someone who has had to scan in
uh document requests that we've gotten
in paper I can tell you it's much better
to get them electronically so uh I hope
you move forward with this I think it
could be stronger and require if a
document exists electronically that the
document is provided electronically um
but I uh support it as it is now
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Mr
mcade uh Jill spet
please thank you Mr chairman Jil Bonet
legal director of the ACLU um this is a
bill oh thank you this is a bill uh we
support I do though think the language
canid should be uh stronger and what
I'll be doing uh in addition to the
written testimony that I'll be
submitting to the committee I'll also
just submit several potential options
for strengthening the language just for
the committee's consideration but I do
want to Echo what this committee has
heard in prior testimony this is like a
growing problem actually where even for
small number of documents one two three
pages that could just easily be emailed
at no cost s some cities and towns are
just making people show up to the
physically during business hours to
their city or town hall or to police
station to collect documents and I've
had this happen to me on multiple
occasions Windam Hancock most recently
Manchester the largest city of the state
is requiring that or at least its Police
Department is with respect to public
records requests even for a two-page
police report you need to show up
physically and get it and you know I'm a
person of privilege and means I can make
that happen if you are not that can and
becomes a problem it is a needless
barrier to access and I don't understand
why some cities and towns are doing it I
just do not because all it does is
hinder transparency and accountability
um so I just wanted to kind of uplift
some of those concerns um why I think
this language could be stronger is
because currently the law is permissive
right like there is nothing in the law
currently that bars a city or town for
emailing documents they are able to not
do it in part uh because of one reading
of the tailor decision which was the is
the decision that you were referencing
before um you know and I just think uh
you know um you know that that that is
the state of the law but we we can do
better we can change the law to reflect
kind of more modern times and given the
ease of technology and I think uh we we
should do that but this language is just
as permissive so it actually is not
going I don't think it would change that
much Manchester even if this were passed
still could just say that's great that
I'm not prevented from emailing
documents but I still don't have to and
I think that is the kind of another
layer of concern I have that I think
there should be some sort of mandate
when it's very reasonable or where the
document size is small the committee can
consider those options and that's what
my testimony does is present some
potential proposals there including some
proposals based on some other states
Rhode Island in Michigan for example so
um that would be that would be my
feedback we support it but we do think
it it can and should be strengthened
yeah representative Smith uh thank you
Mr chair um I I want to make sure you
know that at the moment this bill is
scheduled to be exec by this committee
on Monday so if you have specific
language could you get it to us today so
that um if anyone on the committee is
moved
to prepare an amendment we would have
time to do that before bundai executive
session I just hit sent to the committee
so thank you did you send it
electronically did it was very easy in
fact I didn't have to print it out so
thank you thank you representative Manos
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions aren't there areas
of the state that don't have Broadband
access where electronic Division and
aren't there certainly individual people
who um have Financial barriers to um
accessing records
electronically yes and that that's why I
think one of the one of the proposals
you see in the language is that the
requestor could actually choose if it's
if it's a a size that's very reasonable
they could choose it via email but if if
not the requestor would prefer to show
up they could do that too um and it
allows their requestor to um kind of be
the one whose accomodations are are met
so long as they're reasonable of
course questions for this witness so Mr
B maybe you can refresh my me memory
because I I you remember the name of
wasn't there some discussion in that
case
about the the town having municipalities
having some interest in making sure that
they had a record that they've you know
that they complied and and is is there
something is it somehow easier to do
that if you if you're talking about
paper rather than electronic I just
don't remember what yeah so the two
cases this is going to get very lawyerly
and nerdy I guess uh um so the two cases
obviously the the first dealt with was
the was the Donna uh green case that had
to do with documents in that that were I
think either already in electronically
accessible form or were easily converted
to an electronically accessible form and
the court required that they be emailed
in that instance with respect to the the
tailor case which was uh the the
decision from from your honor there was
a question of whether documents um uh a
similar set of documents though could
just be put on a thumb drive or whether
they could be email and there were some
concerns raised um about kind of cyber
security issues there were concerns
raised about kind of the ability of the
city and town to track how they comply
via email um the I'm not going to
dispute the validity of those things I
think with respect to cyber security
though we're dealing with public
documents so I it is a concern that I I
don't have I I'm less less concerned
about though undoubtedly the
municipalities did there um and and I
would like to think that you know we're
seven years removed from this decision
that we that that emails can be
documented in a sufficient way to be
able to um enable municipalities to
track how they respond sure no that
seems that seems completely reasonable
to me I'm not disputing the concerns
that were raised and they were I'm sure
they were developed with evidence you
know I think maybe this could be an
opportunity to just do some further
modernizing of the statute and I hope i'
I've been able to provide examples great
thank you other questions for this
witness thank you very much uh Katherine
Coco please
thank you um on behalf of right too New
Hampshire we do support this bill as a
clarification um I will reiterate what
others have said we have seen an
increase this is a frequently Asked
question actually we get people who ask
us about um municipalities particularly
Manchester not doing things
electronically and we have seen an
uptick since that message was relaid out
but to nhma members about um not doing
so um more concerned about the use of
the term citizen in this bill uh it
sounds like there may be an amendment
posed but I do want to make the
committee um aware of the language that
is included in the memo that I
emphasized in my previous testimony from
the AG's office where the AG's memo says
that it this um language refers to
Citizens but the right to no law does
not define this term and uses it nowhere
else the statute emphasizes
accountability to the people
accessibility to the public and the
goals of a Democratic Society as an an
agency should not therefore require
persons requesting access to public
documents to demonstrate that they are
citizens of New Hampshire or of the
United States the rk's decision in um
the Rochester case also affirmed that
there was sort of a very broad use of
the term Citizen and we are getting
large number of complaints from people
saying that this standard is now being
applied um so I would recommend changing
that language in particular I'm very
concerned because I had a member of the
press tell me that one of the
communities that was instituting this
rule would not give them information
until they determined where they
lived all right thank you questions for
this witness and that was not Rochester
just to be clear New Hampshire press all
right New Hampshire citizen yes
representative
um Mr chair I have a question for you
unless I'm not looking in the right
direction I no longer see um the
municipal Association lobbyist in the
room and I wonder if we could kind of
put out a call to see if he's in the
building
because he the municipal Association
seems to be
Central to this problem and I think out
of respect for the municipal Association
we owe it to them uh to listen to their
their explanation perhaps they can teach
us
something yes representative
kop thank you uh Mr chairman for
recognizing me and thank you
representative Smith for bringing that
up I did actually text n to ask him
about it and he stated that um he is
following up to clarify on it he knows
that there have been past issues with
advice being interpreted incorrectly so
he's seeking to clarify and and we'll
get back to us once he finds out what
direction was
given what does that mean I mean I mean
is it that
he it doesn't help us I think in that it
might mean that yes this is exactly what
he said but he'd give a better
explanation or it might be that this was
misunderstood so I think we need to hear
and I mean we listen to him a lot and I
think we do him a disservice if we're
not listening to him on
this so what I meant was he said he was
going to follow back up on it he wasn't
sure which it meant he was going to
follow back up sorry I is he still in
the building yeah he was following up
though um I wonder if we could if we uh
if we could ask him to
ah a timely appearance Mr
Graves we would I have yes so uh while
you're U let me let me
call well you're up let me let me call
Dana alri is Dana alri
here okay all right
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record Dana Al Nashua
New Hampshire just very briefly I uh am
somewhat of a frequent flyer on right to
know
requests uh my typical requests tend to
be narrow in scope on average where the
responsive documents are only a few
pages long again typical some
exceptions uh whenever I file one I
actually do site uh green vs Au number
55 and that's it 168 NH
2016 and ask if you've got them in
electronic form please give them to me
in electronic
form
um and people typically reply but I'm
guessing the average requestor doesn't
do that and I'm hearing there's a
problem and I'd anticipate you know if
somebody was anxious enough the remedy
is they could run down to Superior Court
you know complain we're not in
compliance with the decision and do a
whole lawsuit but that's stupid time is
a precious commodity if we can just kind
of help everybody out and clarify this
in statute and just make it uh sort of
more obvious to everyone involved how
we'd like this to work that's a good
thing so I support this great thank you
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir thank you Mr
Grace
thank you Mr chair uh the walls here
have ears um Nate Nate gr for the
municipal Association um
I don't have any opinion on the bill as
written um we're neutral on it but I'm
happy to Supreme Court president that um
if a records request comes in for
electronic
materials those materials have to be
provided
electronically um
as far
as how those are provided whether via
email whether via flash
drive um the Supreme Court has at
present left that up to Municipal
discretion uh
so there was a case involving SAU 55 and
I don't towns have a policy as to
whether those are going to be provide
electronically whether they're going to
be via flash drive and obviously that
has to be applied equally to all
requesters as you've heard from other
hearings today um there are out of state
request stores companies that make
requests and it is advisable for our
municipalities to consider what their
policy is in in relationship to the type
of requests they actually receive um
most companies in Florida or California
are not going to send a representative
to the Town Hall in smalltown New
Hampshire to go pick up a flash
drive but you can't discriminate against
out of state versus inst State and then
you come up with the citizen debate and
what that means
but so
so let me ask you if the if the if this
bill were
rewarded um in in the way that I believe
uh Mr bisonet from the ACL suggested
that would say that the the requester
can kind of request the format that they
want the records in um would you have
any problem with
that
so yes generally because that means that
the government is going to have
to figure out how to set up its system
in whatever manner the requestor
requests if there's some parameters
where oh okay but no no I see you're
saying but I mean suppose it said that
the the the requestor can
request that the the format that the
records be provided
in and the and the municipality must
must comply assuming that they have the
record stored in the in the format
that's requested so they don't in other
words you don't have to if if you don't
have the records in electronic form you
don't have to put them in electronic
form but if you do so if I understand
correctly what the proposal is is the
requestor can say um you know let's say
the records are electronically the
requestor can say I want them in
electronic form don't print them out
right right
um a as I said um
I think the Supreme Court um has
been somewhat clear on this and that if
it's Aran electronic record that's the
format you're supposed to provide them
in the I think one of the open questions
is let's say you have a record that
needs some sort of
redaction um what's the proper way to do
that and I assume that where people are
getting hard copies instead of
electronic copies you have that sit
situation where there a redaction needs
to be made and for whatever reason um
the municipality doesn't have the
ability to do that electronically I
assume that's the
case other questions for this W yes
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
if the person can State how the format
that they're receiving it and I
understand electronic vers vers hard
carpy that's fine but do you perceive
that there may be a potential problem if
they could also determine the delivery
method such as if it would be sent via
email or picked up on a thumb drive the
reason why I'm asking that is would some
towns potentially not have the ability
to email a
large sized file that they would need
some they would need to give on a on a
would that potentially have um
electronic consequences that they may
may not have ability to do that yes I
think so and I email a lot of people and
frequently their mailboxes are set at 25
megabytes so anything over 25 megabytes
is going to kick back so the problem
that you end up with is you send the
email it goes to the recipient's mailbox
quote unquote and then gets
automatically rejected um what exactly
is the municipality supposed to do after
that um one of the one of the issues too
is um we want to make sure that the
records actually get to who they're
supposed to be getting to um so whether
that's a read receipt or dep figuring
out what's appropriate is a problem as
well because we want to make sure that
people actually receive those records um
so if you do something simple like
upload the records to um you know a
Google drive or a box or some a Dropbox
or something like that um there are
settings you can do that tell you you
know who downloads them and when or who
accesses them and when um but that is
all highly dependent on what software is
available and what you're using um and
people may or may not be willing to
click the link that you emailed them
that say go to this website to download
what your records are um so that's there
are a lot of sophisticated technological
hurdles that I am not the person to ask
about because I just don't know that
that background as well right
representative Smith thank you again
thank you for having good ears and
coming back um can I conclude
appropriately that this page that you
were just
shown um that was posted um in New
Durham is not accurate and that in fact
the municipal Association has
not
said that um
um that the town should no longer
provide electronic copies of
documents I would prefer not to provide
comment on anything my members may have
posted on their website thank you very
much and thank you for letting me ask
the question even though I thought I
knew what the answer would be thank you
all right other questions yes
representative CH just just want to
follow up on the point you made
previously do you feel that the way this
is written
um it would there there's a reason to
specify that the town can respond
electronically provided that the person
um receiving the information is able to
make use of that format or or do you
think that that's already
covered
um so I believe the bill is drafted May
provide
some greater specificity to what is
already allowed um
and I so I think it's it's perfectly
permissible for a town to send out
records via email not all of them do
that obviously but um it's possible if
that's within their their policy
guidelines so just quick followup so
this it would the onus would be on the
requester if they're not able to make
use of the that format to to follow up
is that your
thought again I think that it comes down
to the question of delivery of Records
um you know obviously if it's possible
because the person has an email address
they can receive it that would be
helpful I assume that most people act in
a reasonable fashion and if they get an
email kicked back that says this was
denied because it was over the 25
megabyte limit or whatever that someone
would follow up with a subsequent email
or subsequent contact and say hey we
tried to send this to you and you don't
seem to have gotten it how would you
like it um but that's just my
assumption other questions for this
witness thank you very much Mr Graves
thank you um is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
1696 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on uh House Bill
1696 and open the hearing on House Bill
103 um and um I'll recognize ize
representative katab as the primary
sponsor oh for the
citizen for the
citizen the one at gil yes I
yeah all right uh representative
K thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the Judiciary Committee for
the record I'm representative kitlin
cutab from
Windam this bill seeks to require that
if a person is convicted of a violent
felony or a crime against a child
that the initial Prosecuting
jurisdiction would need to be notified
if they were requesting a name
change the reason behind the bill was if
you recall a new story this summer there
was a gentleman who was
incarcerated for murdering his
girlfriend
and he wanted to change his name from
James Covington to Jamari Covington
because he wanted to come out of isn't a
new
man
and I have a few issues with that one
being that his victim doesn't get to
ever come out a new person she never
gets to go anywhere ever again but I
think with that being said
we as people in this day and age that
have access to electronic things perhaps
we we we look into things if we know
that our child is asking to go to
somebody's house and we aren't familiar
with that family we may Google them if
somebody's changed their name
effectively you might not be able to
find their past and if the person is is
seeking
to remove this off of their record in
Statue right
now the victim would be notified and
they'd have an opportunity to to speak
to that so I think that we should
have some sort of a way for that to
happen if the person
is seeking to change their name which is
effectively kind of clearing clearing
their record so this is meant
to ensure that we're protecting the
public really I'm happy to take any
questions questions yes representative
Perez thank you for this bill what
concerns me would this
cover someone changing their name
because of marriage it would Co cover
that as well if a woman got married and
who was a felon of one of these crimes
that it would cover that as
well yes it
would my only concern
is that can we definitely count on the
Juris Prosecuting
jurisdiction getting in touch with the
victim if the victim's still alive
that's my concern do we want to put in
here victim's family or the victim or
whatever needs to be notified because I
don't think that happens all the time I
think things go through the slip through
the cracks and maybe it's because I
watch too much online TV but I think it
happens in real life too so thoughts
yeah so that was actually a suggested
Amendment from the Coalition of domestic
violence and sexual assault so I think
think that that is definitely something
for us to consider and it also included
adding in a couple of other crimes um
and I
think that is another thing to consider
as
well other questions for this witness
yes okay thank you Mr chairman um just a
quick question do any other states have
language or laws like this do you know
of I Haven an expl that but like I said
we do have a statue in process if you
want to clear your your record that you
you have to go through a process so I do
think you know this is kind of similar
in nature and I there is
a
um yeah I'm not sure thank you other
question yes representative Manos thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um on line
five um says person convicted of a vient
violent felony or a crime against a
child and then line 12 is more
specific and I was wondering about the
discrepancy between that between the
specification on line 12 and the lack of
specification on line
five so I was trying not to be
duplicative in nature by just listing
the offenses here because we don't have
a definition currently in statue of
these crimes I was trying to list out
what the crimes specifically would
be
yes it seems to me that line five would
that there could be a discrepancy
because line five does is not specific
and so it could include violent felonies
or crimes against a child that are not
in the list in line 12
I would be amable to a amending the bill
to add this in as a definition instead
and then you know at I guess at the top
as as a definition of what it is and
then just using that terminology if you
feel that that would clarify it better
thank
you representative Waltz thank you for
taking my question um looks like maybe
an oversight but on line six
uh it says the petitioner shall make a
compelling showing I mean do we need
another word in like
statement so this was this statue was
already in place but it was only in
place to notify the department of safety
so that wasn't terminology that I
already had in here the Bold is the part
that I've added so this currently if
somebody was currently incarcerated then
the Department of Corrections would have
to be notified but then there's nothing
requiring once the person leaves prison
for anybody to be notified and further I
there was a case that slipped through
the cracks because the Department of
Corrections was notified but it was the
inproper person that was notified or the
improper department and not the
prosecuting District they they were
never notified so that's just seeking to
clarify that but uh if you think that
what's currently in statute
is just awkward to
read I'm amable to to changing it thank
you other question questions for this
witness seeing none thank you next I'm
going to call on um hamela uh Kelly or
Kylie which Kylie okay thank
you good uh morning or you still oh
afternoon good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Pamela kyg and I'm the public policy
specialist at the new Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence as you might know the Coalition
is the umbrella Organization for our
state's 12 community- based crisis
centers that serve uh nearly 14,000
victims and survivors of Domestic and
Sexual Violence each year um today I am
here in support um of HB 13 which is an
important Public Safety and
accountability measure when it comes to
addressing violent crimes in our state
um as uh the representative uh sponsor
mentioned I do have a couple of proposed
amendments that I think could strengthen
or lend to the spirit of the bill um and
I'm happy to walk through U my testimony
now um so as you heard hb13 will require
offenders who have committed certain
violent crimes to demonstrate a
compelling reason for changing their
name before it can be granted by a court
under current law right now you can
murder someone and change your name why
is that acceptable this means that a
name change is essentially equivalent to
a clean slate for someone who does not
want to be discoverable as a criminal
unfortunately we are aware of many um
cases where offenders have changed their
names for the exact reason to further
victimization to conceal and hide their
identity this is especially true in
cases of Domestic and Sexual Violence
where an abuser often has multiple
victims true accountability cannot exist
without an honest recognition of the
harm caused and the impact that the
crime had on a victim in the community
at large uh we should all have a vested
interest in policy initiatives that will
help prevent further harm we know that
being able to vet an individual's past
offenses is a critical step to assessing
the level of danger someone may pose to
victims in their communities and we
cannot adequately respond to violence if
we pretend that it never occurred this
change to our state law is long overdue
um often after a violent crime occurs
such as domestic violence homicide or
sexual assault people say I can't
believe this happened in my community
when violent offenders change their
names both victims and communities face
an added barrier to being informed about
an offender's whereabouts this
experience is stressful for victims and
dangerous for communities people who
have committed violent crimes shouldn't
be allowed to change their name simply
because they want to reinvent themselves
our communities are at risk when violent
histories are erased from public memory
nobody knows more about the level of
dangerousness than the person who has
been harmed by the offender yet victim's
experiences are rarely considered
credible assessments of an offender's
behavior and their input is often not
treated as valuable and essential
component to their Criminal Justice
System um I really appreciate
representative Perez's question because
we agree that we think um a provision
should be included in this to include uh
victim input um because victim input is
critical throughout the criminal justice
process not just uh prior to sentencing
um and there are a few um examples of
where um in statute the there already is
a place for victims to provide input um
and I have an amendment and some
examples that I can pass around to the
committee um judges cannot appropriately
issue a decision that impacts the victim
in broader Public Safety without hearing
from the people who have been most
impacted by the crimes committed um and
as also uh addressed we think that it
would be beneficial that the definitions
of violent crimes in the statute align
with the annulment statute um because
that is a great standard uh for the list
of violent offenses and would be allow
these two um statutes to really
complement each other um so I think just
to wrap up my testimony we have an opp
opportunity here to take the steps
necessary to improve our state's
response to the devastating impact that
these violent crimes have in our
communities um and this bill will serve
as an important tool to prevent
dangerous people from hiding in plain
sight we need to take the safety
concerns of victims and their families
seriously um and this cannot be achieved
when people who harmed them can erase
their identity uh I really appreciate
your time here today and thank you and
I'd be happy to take any questions
questions for this
witness I don't see any so can you send
um the you have actual drafts of
amendments can you send them oh or I'm
ready for you today great all right
thank you very much thank
you right
great all right next I'm going to call
on Bonnie ciner
please good
morning um I'm very nervous I've never
done this before
um my name is Bonnie Sider and I wanted
to tell you about my personal experience
and why I'm in support of
hb13 um a few years ago I sought the
support of a licensed counselor I wanted
to make sure that I identified someone
who seemed trustworthy so I spent time
carefully researching the backgrounds of
different counselors in my area no raed
flages appeared and everything seemed
fine so I moved forward with scheduling
an appointment I would later learn that
my counselor was involved in three fatal
car crashes due to drunk driving and had
a history of drunk and driving
convictions he was later the first
person in New Hampshire to be convicted
of manslaughter for a drunk and driving
fatality I never would have moved
forward with scheduling to see this
counselor had I known about his
extensive criminal history and
incarceration this lack of information
ultimately Ely led me to be alone in a
room with a man who was very
manipulative and unsafe he sexually
assaulted me on multiple occasions and
to this day the criminal case against
him is ongoing I had done my due
diligence but I had researched the wrong
man the state allowed him to change his
name while incarcerated he hadn't even
been released before working on his
Clean
Slate because he was able to erase his
pass through a name change I was
prevented from truly being able to make
decisions that were best for my safety
it never occurred to me that my
counselor would have changed his name
and that that name change was preventing
me from learning that he was a dangerous
person after learning the truth I felt
so angry and betrayed one of the victims
killed by my counselor was a little girl
who was hit on the side of the road just
after attending a fundraiser with her
father I became even angrier when I
found out that the parents of that
little girl would have opposed his name
change but were not given the
opportunity to weigh in they were only
notified by prosecutors after the change
had been granted not only were the
parents unable to provide a statement on
the serious harm and pain this this man
had caused them but Public Safety was
jeopardized as he was allowed to
victimize other people victims of crime
and their family members should be part
of the process it's not enough for
notification to be made to the
prosecuting agency they need to be
directly looped in their experiences and
what they know about an offender matter
I know this from my own experiences as
my sexual assault case is still pending
going into year four and scheduled
hearing number 25 with zero progress in
the case I have been repeatedly kept out
of the loop by the prosecutor's office
and not informed of my rights as a
victim of crime to weigh in and be in
court had the parents of that little
girl been given the chance to speak at
the hearing where my counselor was
granted a name change the judge might
have had more information to consider
and I would have had the opportunity to
know the truth and make an informed
decision about my counselor thank you
and I would be happy to take any
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
ma'am next I'm going to call on Mary
Bona
please
thank you good afternoon thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee my
name is Mary benia I'm a lieutenant with
the state police um I oversee the
records information services for state
police and I've been on for 20 years now
um State Police is in support of this
bill and for a few reasons and a lot
have already been mentioned um this
allows violent criminals for for
concealing themselves if not pass and
having the opportunity to commit
additional um crimes it also allows this
bill will allow victims that ability to
um oversee the identity of that person
because there are victims out there that
may follow their offenders to make sure
they're in a good safe place from where
they're located it's also good for the
public um as mentioned earlier with
Google and different open sources you're
allowed to use in order to track
individuals and look them up and see if
it's somebody you want your family
around or your neighbors around and
where they're living along with
employers and communities there is some
employment around here that does require
fingerprint checks and those kind of
different situations but there's a lot
of Employments that don't require that
kind of information to be done before
they're um employed somewhere and being
able to Google someone or look up their
history or do some sort of background
check that they do through their own
they can do it that way it also with the
criminal records division needs to
connect those um records with the master
name to the Alias name that now they are
changing their name to because their um
birth name will always be their Master
name in that kind of situation so it
gives a little bit of it could take a
little of a delay and in that small
delay something could happen if that is
not taken care of so State Police is in
support of this Bill thank you questions
for this
witness Mr chair oh yes representative
Loreno thank you for taking my question
and thank you Mr chair um so I'm
thinking about um the sexual offender
registry let's say that we have um a
person um who serve time and um now
they're listed on a sexual offender
registry so if they happen to change
their name um is that reflected on the
registry at all it would be reflected
when um the sex offender registry re
receives name changes because they are
required right now in this law to be
served if they are registering as a sex
offender the department of safety um we
do oppose those name changes due do the
consequences that some may face down the
line um and most of the time they are
they're not granted a name change but if
it is reflected then it would be in
there and um yeah please go ahead may I
follow up so um if this bill were to
pass how would it affect um people from
out of
state that commit crimes in New
Hampshire yes so if they came um I think
they're going to have to do a name
change if their state requires it if
they're in a different state I don't I'm
not aware if New Hampshire gets notified
if there's something that happens in New
Hampshire of that name change because
now they're in another state so like a
sex offender when they leave New
Hampshire they register out of the city
or town they're registered in and then
they have to register as to where they
go so that should
be done in their state thank you thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next I'm going to call on Steve
Anders
please
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Stephen andris I'm
an assistant County attorney in Marram
County I've been a prosecutor now for um
about 23 years maybe a little over that
uh we are in support of of this bill in
the
language with regard to the uh the two
potential amendments the first one being
mandatory victim
notification I I think notifying the
prosecutor's office is is adequate I
don't know that you want to put language
in about mandatory victim notification
the reason I say that is we have cases
where we have victims who essentially
tell us I don't ever want to hear from
you again the case is closed I'm moving
on with my life and every time I get a
call from the county attorney's office
or with reference to what happened in my
case it brings back a lot of trauma so
we've certainly had victims indicate
please don't call me in the future and I
think that that that should be
respected with reference to amending
this
to um reflect the enement statute I
think that's a great idea in New
Hampshire we have an annulment Statute
in RSA
6515 which allows people to enol their
criminal records in certain
circumstances there are certain crimes
listed in
6515 subsection uh 13 and 14 for which a
person cannot get an anold an analment
those are violent crimes as well as
crimes of obstruction of
justice that list is more inclusive uh
than the list that's contained within
the current bill I would note that the
current bill has second degree assault
and trafficking in persons listed in it
which is not listed in the analment
statute so if a person was convicted of
second degree assault they could
potentially anull that conviction
whereas the annulment statute does list
a number of additional crimes including
um manslaughter for DWI which as a
previous witness spoke about this
individual would not be allowed to anull
their record but under the current bill
I think they'd still be allowed to to
change their name without notifying
anyone because manslaughter is not
listed so I do think it it would make
sense to um harmonize this with the the
current enement statute and I'd be have
to take
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank
you all right um I don't have any other
cards is there anyone else who wishes to
be heard on House Bill
103 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
that in recess until one o'clock
thank
you
all right um I'm now uh going to call
the Judiciary Committee back to order
and um open the hearing on House Bill
one4 uh relative to repealing the
judicial conduct commission and I'm
going to
recognize representative uh Caitlyn
kutab as a prime sponsor of the
Bill thank thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee this bill simply seeks to
repeal the judicial conduct commission
statute
494a it was deemed unconstitutional in
2004 and it was it's been left on the
books it's not used it's confusing to
prosay parties who perhaps have a
conduct complaint and they go Googling
to see what process to use the process
that is actually used it has a very
similar name it's also abbreviated JCC
it's the judicial conduct committee and
that is done uh by the court it was it
was just deemed that we're separate
legislative branches we don't get to
have oversight onto them except for the
Constitutional Prov provision where if
they're behaving poorly and we're going
to seek to impeach them essentially so
this is cleaning up the books of a
statue
that is unconstitutional not used and
has been sitting on there confusing
people for more than 20 years now so
happy to take any
questions questions for representative
cutab yes representative Alexander thank
you um Mr chair please help educate me
why was this
commission implemented is that for
legislative oversight on the
Judiciary it was it was it was
implemented uh former uh representative
and Senator I believe Ned Gordon who was
also a retired judge he had done a lot
of work on this um and we argued for it
because we wanted to have some oversight
and uh if it was for if there was
complaints about not only judges but
also clerks um or or other court staff
were included in there and it was just
deemed that the the chief Supreme Court
Justice is who gets to oversee the
judicial branch and we can't mandate
things on them
otherwise just follow up I'm confused
because I thought the
legislature is allowed to kind of guide
the Judiciary and determine whether
they're making decisions that follows
legislative intent and things like that
so that's what's confusing to me
is
that that was that was always my
impression of the three branches of
government so I guess I'm confused yeah
so we while we set policy we don't set
we don't we're not supposed to tell them
how to run their house just like they
can't tell us how to run ours they get
to make their own rules and chairman
Lynn might be able to explain it a
little bit better than I am I'm trying
to pull up pull up the case here um and
I'm sorry one more didn't we just set up
a committee to study the family court so
isn't this like a situation where like
the legislature has commissioned
oversight on the Judiciary to look into
some of these misconduct and provide
suggestions because if they don't if we
don't provide suggestions we would just
tell them right like is I I don't know
I'm confused so I'll I'll leave it at
that yeah so that was supposed to be
looking into irregularities and times
when perhaps policies or that we had set
were not were not being used or if there
were irregularities that we needed to
legislatively implement a new policy to
correct but that wasn't for us to be
looking into specific cases or for us to
be looking at specific judges that's why
it was you know done in a way that it
was you know not supposed to be case
specific other other
questions yeah I you know my my
recollection it's been a while ago I was
that this case was was decided be before
I was on the Supreme Court but my
recollection is that what the the
judicial conduct
commission
was essentially created and it was it
was similar but but in some ways
different than the judicial conduct
committee but it was established by the
legislature and it would have
given this commission the author
basically the authority to discipline
judges in other words to you know to
reprimand or or censure or uh even
suspend a judge and if I recall
correctly um I think it was Judge Neto
uh Joe Joe Netto um who wrote the
decision I think and I think what they
said was that the legis the legislator's
role
in in disciplining judges is impeachment
if the in other words if a judge if you
if the legislature wants to impeach a
judge they can you know the house can
impeach and the Senate would try but
for lesser kinds of things lesser kinds
of violations the the Judiciary gets to
discipline its own basically just like
the legislature gets to discipline its
own that that's I'm I'm I'm I'm probably
oversimplifying because I don't have it
right in front of me but basically that
was the that was what uh the court said
in that case yeah
so I think the last paragraph gives a a
big summary and it it basically just
says that most of the committee's
functions deal with determining whether
it has whether the Judicial Code of
Conduct has been violated and imposing
disciplinary actions by reprimand or
censor nowhere does the text of our
state constitution demonstratively
commit these functions to the
legislature Accord
accordingly
um we find it
unconstitutional
I'm sorry represent ter did you have a
question I I I think I got thank by the
way for your testimony because it
cleared up my confusion about why this
was proposed and and I didn't realize
they were two separate is the is the
judicial conduct committee established
in statute or that's just established
completely by the Judiciary that's
established by Court
rule other other questions for this
witness right thank you very much thank
you uh next I'm going to call on uh
Randall ker
please good afternoon members my name is
Randall CER I'm here to oppose the the
bill um and I want to talk briefly about
what she just spoke to about the
judicial conduct committee and the
reference of the commission uh we have
three branches of government uh for
checks and balances which is correct but
let's review the opposing reasons why
it's deemed unconstitutional by the
Supreme
Court my objections are as follows the
New Hampshire Supreme Court ruled the
commission is unconstitutional the
current judicial conduct committee is
composed of the judges in the New
Hampshire Supreme Court New Hampshire
Supreme Court police themselves through
current legislation this needs to be
changed the new judicial conduct
committee is ruled unconstitutional
because of Judges Who police themselves
and rule that private rules supersede
the federal law um keeping with the
keeping the conduct committee and not
the commission would be protecting the
judges of wrongdoing I filed three
judicial committee complaints all were
dismissed it says a judge can ignore the
facts of the case it's not grounds from
misconduct but if you IGN if you ignore
the facts in the law you certainly can't
have Fair findings of lawful orders if
you don't apply all the facts and the
evidence to make independent judicial
findings
um so in Family Court uh New Hampshire
Family Court rule 2.2 says Rules of
Evidence don't apply in domestic
violence or family cases hence why my
son was stolen by the court 10 years ago
um and they the Supreme Court denied my
appeals um and New Hampshire Supreme
Court rule 2.2
um New Hampshire Supreme Court rule 2.2
says the court shall uphold the law and
perform all duties fairly and partially
be objective and open-minded they must
interpret and apply the law if they
approve if they approve or disapprove of
the law good faith heirs a factor law
does not violate this
rule so here's a
problem New Hampshire Supreme Court
police themselves I'm a military
veteran their own rules that says that
rules of Rules of Evidence don't apply
in domestic violence or family
cases um violate the rule of law the
rule of evidence uh the definition of
the independent Judiciary of which
they're supposed to follow more
importantly Michael Gardner's testimony
In This Very Room to the select
committee that we were talking about
earlier um says that the Rules of
Evidence don't apply cu they want to be
Gatekeepers for what they hope is
reliable
information
um so without actually access to
evidence to defend per the New Hampshire
Court or the New Hampshire mission
statement to follow New Hampshire
Constitution as well as the United
States Constitution there's a there's a
portion in there called Article 15
rights of the
accused if the judge denies the access
to evidence in my case four times in
Family Court which is a non-criminal
court but then they use criminal
statutes to
um basically violate my parental rights
so I can't see my kid and the committee
denies all
three um
complaints nowhere anywhere does it say
in 10 years that I found anything about
this commission um or the executive
director director or um the the current
chain of command so if we get rid of the
commission we actually need this so we
can have
an independent review of what the courts
are doing um however there is there is a
problem with it with a commission where
it says three judges two lawyers and six
Independents but they have to be
independent of the court system so I'm
not sure how judges and lawyers can be a
part of the commission
if uh they're not supposed to be part of
the court system so that has to be
addressed as well um but I just wanted
to to uh oppose the bill and make sure
that we actually have a way um to
redress our grievances as a redress
grievance has been disbanded as well um
but literally we can't find any reason
why it's
unconstitutional um if they police
themselves and private rues supersedes
the Constitution we have all the judges
in New Hampshire committing treason and
they need to be moved for impeachment
effective today I have the evidence in
my federal court case I have the
evidence in my Supreme Court case um
where the Attorney General pleaded
immunity to Federal Court to
constitutional violation
and then it was denied in Supreme Court
so we need checks and balances we're
here to fight for our kids that's what
we're doing we're trying to make sure
everything's right and there's no
possible way that the legislator can
write statute that violates the
Constitution and allow this the Supreme
Court to police themselves how does rule
supersede the Constitution I'll take any
questions all right questions for this
swits seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next I'm gonna call on
Nicholas raldi
please hello I'm Nicholas raldi from
Carol County I'll stand if I may good
afternoon everybody sure so for decades
children had been reporting major abuse
acts against them for decades no one
listened now 2024 we have another
problem in New Hampshire that is also
involved Children and Families where no
one is
listening if we don't have checks and
balances to watch out for these judges
what's not to say that they will operate
in a RICO
manner uh in a racketeering situation
where they allow judge where they allow
lawyers to come in and manifest a case
just to push these cases along that's
happening now people are
telling our Representatives that this is
happening and no one is listening I've
myself watched over a thousand cases
where lawyers have gone in and
manifested uh their stories which
controls the narrative so you could
never go and appeal these cases because
all they do is read The Narrative they
don't even bring evidence up so
for 10 years you might not be able to
have a relationship with your children
some some with younger children could go
18 years with not having a relationship
with their
children the problem now is lawyers and
judges abusing privilege and Power in
the family
courts the guardianship
courts and the juvenile
courts this has led to Monumental crimes
against the public at
large will we wait for decades before
someone of authority actually
listens
will it cost the taxpayers hundred
million
lawsuits in the future if nobody
listens I have said it before and I'll
say it again we are no longer following
the laws of the land we under we are
under a rule of a small committee
abusing the public
record fraud on a level never seen
before in the realm of the best interest
of a single child these lawyers are
making millions of dollars a year off of
the abuse of
children um we all witnessed what
happened with the cunu center children
were telling the parents and adults they
were being abused and no one was
listening again you have fathers and
mothers coming in here and again they're
saying there's a problem there's abuse
and no one is listening and nothing is
changed we don't have a redress
committee
um what I just found out today is when
you send a complaint over to the
JCC they were supposed to send it over
to this this other branch that we're
talking about today and that never
happened those people weren't even put
in place they're they're literally
policing themselves and at the end of
the day 40 years from now it's these
names right
here that ignored this
and now you have a a100 million lawsuit
because we're able to prove Rico you can
literally go into on your computers
right now and there are multiple states
that are F filing Rico charges against
judges
lawyers State officials sheriffs so it's
starting now call it a movement uh call
it justice but it's happening that's why
why we had the special house committee
for the family
courts
um I myself have not had I filed one JCC
complaint uh as a
witness to some
wrongdoing in a different family court
case and mine I'm holding mine back
until 2027 because I'm still in the
courts my child doesn't age out until
2027 and I'm afraid
that if I do file a
complaint it can come back to to haunt
me uh once the judge finds out so I'm
deathly afraid of that affecting my
children uh so I reserve my right to
hold that complaint back when it should
be uh brought to life
immediately again these cases that can
be disposed of uh they go 10 years and
and people are being affected Ed by that
and what we are actually doing is we are
corrupting the future of our children
when you don't have a mother and a
father raising the
children you can only imagine what it's
going to be like 40 years from now so
all right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir uh next I will call on Dana alri
please
good afternoon Mr chairman uh Dana alch
nashio New Hampshire I think uh one
thing we can agree on here there's been
some confusion surrounding this and I
think the other thing I would propose is
that a lot of people feel unheard on
this and I would just recount the
legislative history of this in
2001 the legislature passed uh SB
197 uh it both houses it was signed into
law it created this
clearly at that time in 2001 people
wanted this the people wanted
this and uh in 2003 there were some very
minor revisions made that was House Bill
4 and then when you move forward to 2004
or uh you have the Supreme Court saying
this is uh unconstitutional based on
separation of
powers uh respectfully I think there's a
lot of people out there on the street
who disagree with that maybe they're
wrong if we have
a you know another case where the people
in the Supreme Court have kind of been
at odds has been taxpayer standing you
amend the
Constitution um but I would really urge
you all rather than just sort of throw
this out is to maybe go back to the
record of what happened in
2001 what the people actually
wanted and um what the best way is to
move forward in
providing the oversight to the Judiciary
that I think a very large number of New
Hampshire voters
are looking to have happen all right
thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you thank you I don't have any
other pink cards is there anyone else
who wishes to be heard on um House Bill
104 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 104 and since we
haven't uh noticed the hearing for the
next bill until 145 U we'll take a short
recess until 145 thank
you
than
yes
yeah I
just
yeah
come
sit
k
you
all right uh it's 1:45 I'm going to uh
call the Judiciary Committee back to
order and uh we'll open the hearing on
hb15 uh relative to judicial training
and I'll recognize uh representative uh
cable kab the prime sponsor of the Bill
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the ju area committee again
for the record my name is representative
keitlin cab and I represent
wam this bill seeks to
establish a
Judicial training requirement for judges
both new judges that are coming in and
then continuing ed for our current
judges it also seeks to establish a
Judicial training coordinator
position currently many states have a
Judicial training coordinator that does
this for the judges our state doesn't so
we have an administrative attorney
trying to wear multiple different hats
and do the best that they can to try
and train our judges in the in the best
way that they can however it would be
better as a as a dedicated position in
sitting on the special Family Court
committee there were many
concerns from people regarding their
experiences in court and feeling as
though things were not necessarily
uniform between judges that
sometimes one judge would would apply
something a different way another judge
wouldn't apply it that way and and some
of it really seemed to come down to
training but it became really clear that
it wasn't really just family court that
was a problem it was it was really all
the courts because what ends up
happening is is when a when a judge is
appointed typically they've previously
specialized in a particular area of Law
and then they'll be assigned to work on
something else and it may not be an area
of law that they're particularly
familiar with maybe they were a
prosecutor and they're being assigned to
work in family court maybe they were a a
criminal defense attorney and now
they're being assigned to work in
Probate and we want to make sure that
our judges are up to speed and
and equipped to make the best decisions
and and fair decisions and and applying
the law in the correct way so this is is
seeking to to provide that that training
to them and I'm happy to take any
questions on the bill so I guess one
question I have uh representative kab is
well first I should say is anybody else
have I yes representative
testman I realize there's not a there is
apparently not a clerk or somebody to
take care of the the training and so on
but could isn't this something that
should be handled by the judges outside
the legislative
oversight there's there's more than
enough
people in the system already
probably that they could Tas one or two
people to do this why is this a special
law you why is that
required thank you for the
question
so some of it comes down to cost so sure
you could just say the judges can can go
and and and go to a training as they see
fit and there are lots of conferences
that maybe apply these things but then
ultimately if you have judges flying out
to several different conferences in
different states that that is going to
cost much more money than the cost of a
training coordinator but also you don't
have somebody that is kind of kind of
trying to plan hey these trainings might
be available on this dates and maybe
it's possible to bring the trainer here
to our judges so that they can all get
the training together collectively at
the same time um and and to really look
ahead and do these things because it
does become difficult once you have
judges that are assigned to cases and
they may be booked months and months and
months out to give them that time off to
even go to a training at all and
so presently there
is a complaint from the public that
perhaps there is a lack of training with
with the judges and I don't think we're
giving them the tools necessarily to be
able to do that because they are very
understaffed as it is so to ask them to
do all of this additional planning when
we've already got judges that
are writing decisions literally at home
because there's no time during the day
for them to possibly do that work and
they're working through lunches so I
think it's another task to put on them
when they're already very underst
staffed yes representative
tur y uh thanks and thanks for taking
the question um I was just curious about
the different hour requirements that are
in the proposed Bill and and where they
came from I thought is is this based on
something from another state or some
sort of known number or how were those
determined um it came from another state
yes um and I would just note that I I do
think that the number of continuing
hours are
pretty mod like they're they're pretty
it's a pretty modest number uh when you
look at
as you know for doctors when they're
doing their CME they've got to complete
40 hours every year I think it's 80
hours every bium so we're only asking
for 24 hours here so I think it's a very
reasonable amount for the judges to
complete yes representative gon thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative uh who
determines what courses would count as
continuing education what is the
accrediting agency what where's the list
of classes that would be
allowable so that's the purpose thank
you for the question that's the purpose
of of having the training coordinator to
kind of see what areas may be may be
needed what programs are best because
there have
been there have been remarks regarding
you know hey this training put on really
wasn't very beneficial it was kind of a
waste of time and so we want to make
sure that we are if we're going to have
the the judges take the time to go to
these trainings that they are actually
beneficial to them and so that's that's
why having the training coordinator
would really be beneficial to to be on
top of evaluating and knowing what would
or wouldn't be wouldn't be
helpful other other questions so uh oh
yes I'm sorry representative uh tur
please yeah sorry one one other thing
that I I was looking at is that that the
the language on uh 24 line 24 seems to S
of page one suggests or well uh suggests
that it says um officers shall be
required to complete continuing
education and then all the stuff below
it sort of talks in terms of
maze um so I wasn't sure if there's
consistency between those and how do
those reconcile with each other so that
was guidance that I got back technical
guidance that I got back from the court
that they felt
that it needed to be done under the
direction of the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court to
be other they questioned if it was
constitutional for us to mandate without
it going through the Chief Justice or
that and I would I if I may I would
respond to that I with great respect to
the court have the utmost respect for
the court but frankly I think that
concern excuse my language is BS um it's
um the um the there is I see absolutely
no reason why the legislature couldn't
mandate that there be that there be
training I mean that seems to me and you
know the argu I've I've heard this
argument before um even when I was on
the when I was on the court some people
had it saying well wait a minute how can
the
legislature mandate something for
another branch of government well if
that we're TR try to follow that through
if we can't mandate training with
requirements for the for the court
because it's another branch of
government how can we mandate training
requirements for any any of the
executive branch agencies that's another
branch of government too but we have
there's all kinds of laws that have you
know that mandate various things that
agencies of the executive must do and
those are not uh those are not
unconstitutional I certainly agree that
there would be a you know that there
would be a point at which the Judiciary
which we couldn't go we couldn't go you
know um we probably couldn't tell them
for example you will you have to hire Mr
Smith to be the training person or Miss
Jones to be the training person or
whatever that uh that would seem to me
to go much too far but to Simply mandate
um that there be training I don't see
any any reason why we couldn't do that
and frankly I think the point you rais
representative tus is really a good one
to you know that all these all these
statements like the the you know the
court or the judges made you what why
are we passing a law that says they may
do something I mean if they they may do
something right now as uh we without any
law at all so I I think that to me if we
think that it training is important and
it sounds like you know it sounds like
we do and I I I certainly share that
view then I don't think that there's a
problem with with doing what this does
simply saying that there shall be
training it's obviously up to the court
um to determine what that what the what
the uh training component shall consist
of who shall do the training that that
kind of thing I think that should be
left to them uh but anyway I'm sorry
representative Smith thank you excuse me
thank you Mr chairman I do want to note
that um serving on the special committee
on the Family Court I am chair of the
subcommittee on education training and
accountability and for those of you who
don't feel you spent enough time here
tomorrow um after we quickly go through
our very important executive session if
you walk down the hall I hope at 10
o'clock um that subcommittee is meeting
and the court will be present so I am
told so it's based on my experience on
that matter I do want to object to the
fact that the chair said that we
couldn't say that Mr Smith could be
hired I wondered about Mrs
Smith moving past that point however um
I uh
seriously uh have concerns
about
um the the language that directs the
responsibility
exclusively to the Chief
Justice um um I just as I respect the
governor just as I respect the speaker
of the house and the president of the
Senate I respect the Chief Justice in
the old days we used to stand up when
the Chief Justice came into a
legislative committee but nowadays we
don't seem to have respect for anybody I
have respect for the chief justice but I
also know that for example the Chief
Justice himself the current chief really
never tried a case never had experience
in a
dozen areas Central to the work of um of
the courts and I don't think he has ever
had experience on either the superior
court or the circuit court and uh the
chief justice has lots of AIDS and
assistance the um judges in the family
court for example example have no AIDS
they have to write literally write their
decisions themselves by hand and I have
no problem with their working through
lunch or working they're not they're not
hired to work a 40h hour week I don't
have any problem with them having to
work all week and I work all weekend and
so do you but what I do think they need
is help and assistance so when they
just I'm making a speech and I know I'm
supposed to ask a question and this the
chair has very kindly not stopped me so
I'm going to stop myself except to say
that
I I have problems
about the Chief Justice having the
authority and this bill saying May
instead of shall because they should
have been doing this for years and they
haven't and we and we see again and
again well meaning people appointed to
the bench wanting to do the right thing
but don't necessarily have the skills
and we should
require as we represent the people of
the
state that so could I ask you what you
would feel see I have a question in here
someplace what you would feel if we got
rid of May and put shall in there even
though the court might not be happy I
think that that's a wonderful suggestion
and I would be happy to put in that
amendment to OS this afternoon so that
we have it in time for Monday and I you
you may put me as a co-sponsor of that
amendment I because I completely agree
with you there thank you may I put you
as a co-sponsor to it as well to the
amendment yes are you going to take care
of this with OS I'm happy to if you if
that's okay that's that's great I'm
always happy to have other people do the
work
oh yeah I'm sorry representative lza
please um also in saying that
um in regards to being on that special
committee the other thing is to keep in
mind that we have uh nine judges that
they're looking to for the budget and
that with this training um why we heard
that many not everybody is um was let
you say goes from one Court to another
so um um especially to be able to be
flexible and to hear the education that
they can um would get with their
training is is really invaluable because
they need to be able to be more flexible
to go from one Court to another when
there is an um an absentee or something
that's going on that to be able to go
from one Court to another um and so to
have that training is really valuable we
really need that to be
done yes representative Stapleton thank
you for taking my
question um assuming that these judges
and justices are
lawyers with a law license doesn't their
license require continuing education as
a part of that
lure I believe that the required
continuing education was eight
hours but I what I don't know is if
you're currently a judge if you have to
have a law license
uh well you know this is an well first
of just to answer your specific question
there is actually um if you are a
judge at least a full-time judge and
that's Mo that's most of them now you
are exempt from the continuing legal
education requirements of the bar
association because the theory being
that you're supposed to comply with with
the continuing legal education
requirements of the judicial branch so
it's that they so that's uh but on the
the other question about whether you
interestingly I believe that there is a
that there is a
statute that requires Circuit Court
judges or what used to be called the
District Court but Circuit Court judges
to be lawyers but that's in the statute
that's not in the Constitution there's
nothing as I as far as I'm aware there's
nothing in the Constitution or in
statutes that requires a judge of the
superior court or the Supreme Court to
be a lawyer I think that's right um
obviously you know there hasn't been a
judge that hasn't been a lawyer uh on
the superior court or the Supreme Court
as far as I can remember ever when I
first started practicing in New
Hampshire in the late 1970s there were a
few uh what used to be called municip
mulle Court judges who were uh who were
non- lawyers but were judges and and I
have to say some of them were very good
I mean they were you know they were they
were you know respected members of their
local community and they were they were
very good but they did not have uh they
did not have legal training uh but I
think that I think we you know with the
last non lawyer judge uh retired or
resigned or whatever you know probably
more than 25 years ago 30 maybe 30 years
ago
thank
you question yes representative test the
if I remember right and I'm an engineer
so I can be wrong uh
the the court or the actually the people
put in a constitutional amendment 76a or
B or something like that uh that
said the court can can make all the sort
of administrative laws and rules and
everything else about their people but
then they added and this was not part of
what the vote was voted on and it will
have the force of law so effectively
they became
legislators although not part of what
they vot what they put up for voting so
you I think this is quite quite makes a
lot of sense to give the chief of the
chief of the Court you know this kind of
responsibility I think he needs it
other other questions yes representative
Dorena uh thank you for taking my
question
um so for um continuing education for
judges in New Hampshire what would the
curriculum be would it be specific to
New Hampshire law or could you go out to
a a vendor that does judicial training
thank you for the question so in my
conversations with the court regarding
training it could be some it could be
best practice thing so some of the
topics that they're trained on for
example are domestic violence they're
not necessarily law specific so some of
the training pieces may not be specific
to to New Hampshire
law and I think the the committee that
rep Smith is is chairing is going to be
further exploring which topics make
sense for family law perhaps
may I follow up of course so seeing that
um since there are caned programs um
nationally maybe locally does it really
make sense to have a um a coordinator of
judicial training when it could be when
the training piece could be part of HR
or part of um the chief Justice's
um
duties so as I thank you for the
question so as I as I have mentioned to
rep testerman before I I really believe
that in order to do it efficiently and
effectively we really do need the
position most other states have this
position um and I think it needs to be
planned because we do have our our
judges assigned to cases much in advance
and particularly in in family law we
were trying to go by the principle of
one family one judge although it's
broken quite a bit we shouldn't be
striving for that and so we want to make
sure that if judges are booked out for
cases that they're able to be on those
cases so we need somebody to do a little
bit of planning to make sure that when
these trainings are happening you know
they're they're scheduled in an
appropriate way and we're making sure
that we're not disrupting cases to do
them either but we certainly do need to
make training be a priority I think that
what's currently happening isn't working
and we need to change something to make
it work because I think this could be
happening now but it's not so I think
we've got to take a step to fix the
problems that are
happening representative
gson thank you Mr chair
um you're establishing a position of a
training
coordinator but you do not
detail what the responsibilities are
going to be for said person and then
also any
consequences for how how does that
coordinator hold these judges and clerks
accountable what are the consequ quences
if they don't complete the the requisite
number of hours uh
so it it's it's important that training
gets done but what happens if it doesn't
get done thank you for the question so
that the training coordinator it is
defined actually in the the first
paragraph it says the training
coordinator shall develop highquality
judicial training Branch training and
continuing education programs and work
to provide judges administrators and
Court staff with reasonable opportunity
to fulfill any mandatory orientation and
initial training as well as continual
education requirements in terms of what
happens if they don't complete them the
reason that that piece isn't in there is
similar to what we talked about with the
JCC before where the disciplinary
actions are supposed to be left with the
the chief justice so if if they're not
complying with it that part would be up
to the Chief Justice to to do what he
saw
fit uh represent Smith did you have a
question
no um all right uh thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on Dana
alre
please thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee again Dana alre
nashille and New Hampshire um uh first
let me say I support the bill second let
me say I support some of the ideas I
just heard to strengthen it and third
I'd like to offer uh some additional
suggestions uh to strengthen this and
make it uh even better than it already
is uh to that end uh I'm going to
seemingly briefly drag back to a couple
points you heard this morning on right
to no
bills uh and just everything you heard
on the importance of open transparent
government uh while there may have been
differences of opinion I don't think
anybody this morning thought that
government shouldn't be open transparent
or
accountable
um and so uh sort of along with that I
heard questions from rep gon about you
know what does this training look like
like who's accrediting it uh can we find
out more about the training and also
questions about what do we do for
accountability and you know if something
goes wrong and to sort of follow up on
that I would bring us back to article 8
of our state
constitution that uh says magistrates
and officers of government are supposed
to be accountable I think that certainly
includes the Judiciary and also that uh
access to governmental proceedings and
Records should not be unreasonably
restricted uh per the
Constitution uh so with that background
the amendment I would suggest to this
and what I think the missing piece
is uh is the ability for what all of
this training is to be visible to the
public for the public to ask just you
know as you have what training materials
are we using we can leave it up to the
Judiciary to decide that but I think
we'd kind of like to have some
visibility
into you know if this is implemented uh
how's it going what are you guys you
what are the Judiciary using and so
on and so I would suggest uh adding a
provision in here maybe section seven or
whatever to
specifically uh make it explicit that
these judicial uh training materials are
governmental records uh excuse me
governmental proceedings and Records
within the meaning of article
8 uh so that um reasonable right to know
requests can be fulfilled on those and
sort of the basis for that
suggestion uh I passed out two handouts
uh everybody here should have one that
looks pretty thick but it's really just
uh Supreme Court decision uh Petition of
Union Leader Corp uh 147 NH
603 uh decided
2002 and if you want to do a deep dive
into that uh there's even the complete
transcript of oral Arguments for that
but sheds a little more light on the
Court's
reasoning uh but my position would be
these training materials definitely
would pertain to the a judicary function
of the courts if it pertains to the
adjudicatory functions people should
have access to that uh and that's how
I'd read Petition of union leader but uh
I can be wrong I've been wrong many
times in my life and apparently right
now my understanding is the judicial
branch doesn't agree with that uh
because the second thing I passed around
uh is a response I received essentially
to a right to no
request uh asking what the the current
training materials are and can I please
see them and the answer to that was
no uh
and uh so that's why I think this is
needed is sort of the second piece so we
all the public has a just a good idea of
what they've chosen and we have
visibility into this process and with
that I'll take any questions if
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr next I'm going to call
Randall uh uh Salis caller Coler sorry R
caller
caller thank you for committing for
letting me ask some questions regarding
this training um in regards to Michael
guard 323 testimony here in the same
room regarding the judges not getting
the proper
training um I have a medical license for
over 20 years and I understand
continuing education and every two years
we have to do 60 hours of continuing
education it's not necessarily to train
us to do different things it's so that
we understand that we know what we're
doing um and I I kind of want to bring
the training back to the legislative
body um you know right ing statutes that
that clearly violate law as a Madbury
verse Madison 1803 any law repu to the
Constitution must be anul and and and
repealed
um is it the training of the Judiciary
or or the
courts um or their understanding that
that rules do supersede the Constitution
and and how is that training um being
implemented on the legislative side to
the people actually writing the statutes
and allowing this to happen um I'm not
sure it's any training is needed uh for
the
judges because if the rules if their
private rules supersede the Constitution
when you go to law school I assume
you're taught that you take an all to
defend the Constitution as of military
veterans to defend against this country
against enemies foreign and domestic
obviously the judges are domestic
enemies because rules supersede the
Constitution um so again I have
questions regarding the training as well
but uh is the
training going to be able to
differentiate how their rules supersede
the Constitution and laws um I'm just
curious to that as well and I'll take
any questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you sir uh
next I will call on ncol Nicholas
ronaldi it's clear and convincing that
we have three people here today that uh
have have done with this and have a lot
of
experience um I would I only want to
make a
recommendation uh to cover the checks
and balances to make sure that and to
give the the trainer the authority to
implement uh dummy cases going in front
of these judges so that you have the the
ability to see if their training is
working uh that can be established other
states are doing it uh the judges shall
not be aware of it uh and we put these
people to the
test and I think by doing that not only
will you solve a lot of your problems
but you'll find a lot of the wrongdoers
as well so uh I think that should be
implemented in what is allowed with the
the the trainer uh through facilitating
education to these judges uh that I
believe is needed
um I believe also that a lot of these
judges don't want to deal with the
family court because of the problems
within Family Court nobody likes to
uh how how do you say deal with other
people's problems uh so so it is a it is
a situation where
finding uh proper judges to deal with
with these these cases on an individual
basis through that training and that the
authority should be given to the trainer
to know who those people are as well
because like Mrs Smith said some people
just don't have the skills and when you
run into that
situation uh it can make a cloudy day uh
very quickly so again uh with a trainer
it's a good idea uh but having those
checks and balances
in place to know that the training is
working has to be established because
anybody can go sit in school and you
know I put my glasses on and you don't
know if I'm paying attention or not I
so that's where that's where I think
we're at and to break the I'm sorry but
it's the good old boy routine uh that
should also be in training as well
because they take full advantage of that
privilege uh when and uh these
individuals get comfortable with each
other they tend to pass over uh
crucial uh things that uh could help a
lot of situations so uh through training
they should be trained not to do that so
training should be working both ways on
things that uh should happen and things
that shouldn't happen and and that all
should be clear to the public so we know
what our our our judges are being
trained in um again it's transparency is
probably key here so all right questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
sir uh is there anyone else who wishes
to uh testify on
hb15 relative to judicial
training oh yes come on
up
good afternoon Representatives my name
is Aron krian I'm the general counsel
for the judicial branch um and I've I've
come to try to answer any questions I
know I've I've seen some discussion so
I'd like to make myself available to do
so and I suppose I will have to engage
in the Fool's errand of discussing with
a former Chief Justice and the current
head of the house Judiciary Committee uh
the ex act parameters of what
constitutes an administrative
responsibility under uh article 73a and
and some of the technical advice that I
may have given and I'm happy to do
that um I'm I don't I I don't have any
questions right now but if I mean if
there if there's something that you
think we um you know we should know
about uh please tell it tell us I may
have in particular with regard to the
next bill I may have there may be some
some questions but does anybody have
questions for this
witness yes representative Staples yes I
I'd like to know what you have in mind
relative to this bill if it's useful
compliant with what you're already doing
um different what whatever the substance
of your anticipation of this bill's
value thank you for that question um
there is no doubt that we would benefit
from more training uh it is something
that we're very supportive of and that
the ways that that can accomplished are
many um appointing a Judicial training
coordinator is something that other
states do we do not have a dedicated
judicial training coordinator currently
um a lot of our training is done either
by the training staff that we have in
our HR department um or by the circuit
court or a superior court administrator
who have many other duties and make make
the time to do this um so it is it is
one of many ideas to improve our
training but it is it is one that we
would certainly adopt and utilize if if
the position were created and funded
uh I I say that without any Prejudice
any other ideas uh the legislature may
have about improving training but we can
always do better a major limitation for
our Circuit Court judges is workload um
even when we have training and funds
available we are simply not able to get
them off the bench uh and I know that
that's something many representatives
have been very dedicated toward working
on and ensuring that we can get more
judges so that we can free them up uh to
to even receive the training opposed to
being on the bench so many days but it
is something that we would like to do
more of we're absolutely happy to do
more
training yes so I would take that you're
in support of the bill even in a general
sense the only thing I would say is
representing the judiciaries we always
defer to the legislature on policy
matters and there are many ways to
improve training and so I I would not
want to interfere with the debate that
you have about the ways to accomplish
that but we would certainly if at this
position were created and fund it
utilize it oh is there any idea of how
this might be better made any particular
items well I uh I had uh given uh rad
the advice that uh if it were structured
in such a way that it uh complied with
the chief Justice's administrative
Authority that that is why I believe she
added some of the language on the Chief
Justice being the person to administer
it that that uh may make the the statute
more durable so for example in the most
recent Bill we were discussing which was
relating to the legislatively created uh
disciplinary committee for judges was
ultimately ruled to be unconstitutional
on the basis that discipline had to was
an administrative function one that the
Chief Justice held and I I don't think
there's definitive law on this issue but
if if one can't discipline members of
another Branch the M may not be able to
set a training requirement either that
seems to be substantially a Personnel
related issue that I I did want to
advise the rep I think there there could
be some risk there but that's not an
advanced opinion it would it would have
to be litigated and another judge may
come out another way on that issue but I
certainly try when uh I I receive
questions to flag that there could be an
issue there and that I'm happy to work
with folks to try to structure things in
a way where we can work cooperatively
with the legislature to implement your
policy intention uh without potentially
creating for example a legal challenge
but there's not an overstep problem at
this point with the way this is written
at this point as you see it that's the
advice that i' I'd given to the rep okay
thank you representative
Smith thank you um does the legislature
have the
authority to
um uh to create uh additional
judgeships yes ma'am I believe you do
and could you tell me how that differs
from an authority to create an
additional staff position I think that
you can create additional staff
positions uh and that's something that
you you have done historically I think
that when sometimes when something gets
into the day-to-day administration of
the Personnel that comes more within
what one might consider to be
administrative in nature but certainly
that term as it exists in the
Constitution has has been litigated will
be litigated exactly what it covers is
Administrative versus not well um Am I
Wrong is is the Supreme Court the only
Court that's actually specified in the
state constitution is I know it is in
the Federal Constitution but in the
State Constitution are the other courts
the superior court is also a
constitutionally created Court okay but
not not the Circuit Court no ma'am that
is by
Statute thank you thank you very much
you know just question my my impression
and again it's the firstand experience
is four years old now more than four
years old but my my experience uh from
when when I was in the judicial branch
was that often training matters uh
particularly for judges was sort of um
was kind of an add-on Duty so to speak
of whoever either the Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court or the Chief Justice
of super court or the administrative
judge of the circuit court
and depending on all the other things
that whoever that judge was uh had to be
done it got more or less attention and
so
if we created this training coordinator
position that would that would be the
job of that person and I take it that's
one of the things you were sort of
getting at before yes sir that is
correct it is an ancillary Duty for most
people who work in this area and that
means if they have something that is
either more urgent or more important uh
then that whatever is more urgent or
more important may get more attention uh
if if you give someone a first priority
of being training there should not be
something that comes before that prior
priority other questions yes
repres do you read this legislation to
indicate that the training coordinator
would be responsible directly to the
Chief
Justice I don't ma'am although I I would
not want to ever represent that I am
making a definitive assessment of it but
the way that I read it it's at the
direction of the chief justice that
could also be a delegated responsibility
thank you very much my particular
concern
Mr chair is that the demands of judges
in the Circuit Court differ dramatically
from the demands on the Superior Court
judges and on the Supreme Court judges I
I agree completely and so I think it's
important to be able to have depth and
breadth in handling that I I agree I
agree completely with that thank you all
right thank you very much thank you
you
certainly
okay being that's 2:30 we'll now open
the hearing on house build
1274 and representative Lynn the floor
is
yours thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um I I have uh uh referred to
this bill as sort of the judicial
cleanup bill and I did that because uh
in speaking with uh members of the
judicial councel who are here uh in the
event that you have any detailed
questions about the problems I will try
to address as we go through this um the
uh what the the various things that the
bill is trying to accomplish and why uh
but if my uh if if I if you have
questions that I don't the detailed
answers to I'm going to I'm going to
defer to the people who are the experts
um but basically this bill was designed
to um uh correct a number of things in
current law that for one reason or
another um uh are not in accordance with
uh kind of
what current practice so to speak and so
for example in the um in the first
section um you'll notice that the uh on
line four it changes from four to five
the number of uh the members of the
judicial branch administrative Council
because in fact there are five members
now and not four as there used to be um
uh the uh on line seven um they uh in
terms of um of uh the composition of the
judicial Council
uh the the words the word or
administrator um is added to clerk
because over time you it used to be in
the judicial branch that um the the
clerks of the various courts were sort
of the
administrators um and there was less for
lack of a better term
centralization over time that has
changed quite a bit and so admin there
are now many administrators in the
judicial branch and so this is designed
just to ensure that that those people
may be uh um may be covered in terms of
being eligible to be members of the
judicial council with regard um to uh to
line
16 uh for the par the sections 8 Roman
numeral 8 and and Roman numeral 9 um
you'll notice that um it is uh it is
changed the the language is changed to
propose that um there'll uh there shall
be uh eight me eight other members
appointed by the governor and Council
three of whom shall be lawyers of white
experience and at least two of whom
shall be members of New Hampshire bar
and basically what that was as you'll
see the change basically says that not
every um member has to be a member of
the New Hampshire bar uh there can be
there can be some that might be a member
of that might be lawyers but not members
of the New Hampshire bar and and I will
tell you and I will ask uh my my
colleagues who who may come to testify
after me um that that I think one of the
reasons for this was that there was
there was uh uh uh Mr shil for example
mentioned to me that there was that
there was a person who would be a a
really who who was in New Hampshire now
had been in New Hampshire for a while
would would appear to be someone who
would be a really excellent person to
serve on the judicial Council but was
not a member of the New Hampshire bar
and should that person um be
automatically not not eligible to serve
um while at the same time he recognized
that there we we we want to make sure
that we have ample representation of
people who are members of the New
Hampshire bar so that's why the wording
was changed um in that regard and I'm
hoping that he would be able to speak
more you know if you have questions he
would be able to address that uh in more
detail um and the same is true in
paragraph nine
um with regard to moving on to page two
uh in section three of the bill uh the
the changes made there are
designed basically to make to bring the
law uh back uh to to be consistent with
the fact that the felony
first program has been is ending um
you'll you'll see the language that um
online on page two line 8 which is where
where it says the person uh this is an
arrested person shall be taken to appear
before a circuit court um or uh a
superior court whereas the old language
said taken before a circuit court or in
the case of a felony complaint and
misdemeanors and violation level charges
that are related directly to those
felonies that that was the language that
was in effect when the felony's first uh
uh system was in in a in place and now
that since that's been repealed that
language really doesn't make sense
anymore so that's the reason for that
um lastly in section
four
um this uh is designed that this is
designed to add a new to add to RSA 604
A2 uh a new paragraph
2A that um basically says that there
um uh that the court May uh appoint a
contract
attorney uh or other qualified attorney
in the first instance um if it is in the
interest of Justice to do so and let me
give you the example of um of uh where
of where this might come into play
normally as you probably know some of
you who've been at least some of you
have been around for a while the
the the way the Indigent defense system
works is that the first if if somebody
is Indigent and need is charged with a
crime or needs representation the first
place that that per that that the person
goes or that the court appoints uh an
attorney to represent the person is the
public defender if the public Defender
is not available or has a and often it's
the public defender is not available
because there's a conflict of interest
if the public defender is not available
then it would go to a contract attorney
attorneys who have contracts with the
with the court system to provide
representation and then if that if there
was no contract attorney available then
it would go to to another attorney who
would you know be willing to to serve um
uh as attorney for the
individual
sometimes what what may happen is there
may I give you this example and I think
Mr sril uh or Mr Bucky may be able to
articulate on this better but as I
understand it you may have you may have
a
circumstance where the public defender's
office has a conflict in a particular
case they can't represent Mr Smith let's
say I I let me Mr X let me change that
to Mr X the public defender office can't
represent Mr X uh in a particular case
so a the um uh and let's assume that
there's not a contract attorney
available but so you go down to the
third level so the court appoints
attorney Jones to represent Mr
X now Mr X as not infrequently turns out
to be the case now Mr X is charged with
another crime and the public defender
office doesn't have a conflict in the
other case the way the law work works
now the public defender office would be
appointed in that second case and what
the judicial Council reports to me and
it seems to me to make some sense is
sometimes that doesn't make it it it
just doesn't make sense to have the one
defendant have two lawyers it might make
more sense if there's a if if another
lawyer has been if a non-public Defender
has been appointed to represent the
person in the first case it would just
make more sense for that per that lawyer
to continue to represent the the person
in the second case for continuity
purposes and that kind of thing um
now I'm told and I the judicial Council
I believe believes that that it's the
case that this doesn't happen all that
often uh because there is a cost
consequence to that to it when it
happens um but the judicial Council
believes I think that that for the rare
case where that does where that does
make sense to to allow the the uh
non-public Defender to represent the
person in a case even though the public
defender might not have a conflict in
that case it's worth doing um we put in
some language in here as you'll see that
requires a sort of an accounting by the
court system of exactly how often does
this happen how much money is it really
costing if it you know if it turned out
that it was not really pretty rare and
that it was costing a lot of money U we
might want to rethink that but it's but
I think for a it does it seemed to me to
make sense to do that at least on an
experimental basis let's see how it
works out it does seem like um uh if
there are not significant cost
implications that it that what the what
the judicial Council Rec uh suggested
makes sense and that's why I put it uh
put it in there so I think
um I think I've kind of covered I'm
happy to answer questions uh uh and and
as I say I may defer to uh to the to the
experts but I'm happy to answer
questions representative
Smith thank you very much um because in
Hampshire we have what I think is
politely referred to as a unified bar
and what I refer to is the fact that the
bar association is a wholly own
subsidiary of the Supreme Court um and
that I was under the impression that in
order to practice law and be called a
lawyer in New Hampshire you had to be a
member of the bar so the first example
that you gave where there might be
someone who is
not licensed as an attorney in New
Hampshire but has great skills does that
person have the right to be referred to
as a lawyer rather than as a citizen in
the
Hampshire my I think my answer would be
the person does have a right to be
referred to as a lawyer although they
are not allowed if they're not a member
of the bar they're not allowed to
practice law in New Hampshire but I I
don't I I would think that being a
member for example of the judicial
counil would not constitute practicing
law that would be my you know if I could
except that they would be
appointed I think and tell me I'm wrong
as a
lawyer that's kind of what it
says um lawyers of wide experience at
least two of whom are members of the New
Hampshire bar which would mean that the
other one is also a lawyer of wide
experience and that's why he's he or she
is being appointed right but I guess I
would say I don't think that that would
I mean we you know there are there are
various circumstances in which people
that are not um uh new are not members
of the New Hampshire bar uh are are even
permitted to pra to actually appear in a
case that you know they appear prohack
what's called prohack vichi from another
from another state um so there are those
circumstances but I guess what I would
say here is that it's because the person
by being a member of the judicial
Council would not be practicing law that
would not be that would not be a
violation of you know they they would be
not they would not be engaging in the
unauthorized practice of law thank you
very much
representative tur thank you thanks for
taking the question um my questions on
this bill mostly pertain to um section
two I guess it is which starts on line
26 um and before I asked those specific
ones I'm not sure I heard you address
that section when you were presenting so
I thought maybe I I'll first hear what
the the thinking behind yes no I'm sorry
you're right um my understanding here is
that there
was somewhere along the way before this
there was some change in law that
inadvertently removed
the uh fees for
Witnesses um and that this is basically
intended to put it back um again I um
I'm going to defer to the uh people who
actually are are responsible for paying
these kind of things um who who may be
able to give more information on this
but that's my that's my understanding is
that we were just there was a there was
a change an inadvertent change that
eliminated this requirement and that we
were just putting this back okay can I
can I ask
follow um so uh and again maybe it's for
someone else to answer my two specific
questions I'll start with one which is I
noticed it says 17 cents per mile when
um I wasn't sure how that was
established given the fact that that we
get the the grandio fee of 65.5 cents
per mile for for our travel that again
what what I do remember this that it
was you know even going back years it
was always the case that uh uh Witnesses
and I think maybe it's even
jurors um are the the the rate at which
they're compensated for mileage was
significantly below the IRS rate I think
that had that had sort of historically
been the case and
so my my in my understanding is that
that you know that's why this number was
put in it um because that was sort of
consistent with what had been the case
in the
past okay yeah it just felt a little in
you're right mean congruent for us to to
have a much lower rate in the
bill um
can I ask one more followup follow up
yes um also in that section on line one
of page two um it's it says where the
witness is required to leave the city or
town or city in which the witness
resides um I guess representing a town
that has a major Court in the in the
state in Brentwood
um I'm wondering whether that Clause is
really why that Clause is necessary um
because our our court is you know at
least at the moment right on the border
of the next town There's a lot you know
it's not a great amount of travel that
anyone would be involved in from our
different towns but I'm wondering why it
specifically means you have to leave
your town or if there's a scenario that
that has to be there to cover yeah I
again I think that this is the way it's
it's worded this way because of of sort
of historically in other words this this
whole section was
basically reinserting
something that had been as I understand
inadvertently taken out of Law and uh
with with as as a result of some other
change to the law and this was kind of
putting it back in so um you know I if
we were writing on a clean slate um you
know the various things that you've
raised I think are valid very valid
points that if we were writing on a
clean slate we might want to say well
wait a minute why are we paying less
mileage or why do you have to go out of
your town town when you know um but I
think
this the the impetus for this was to
make the correction to uh you know to
reinstate in the law what had been and
what was thought to be necessary um
without sort of would make while making
the the least amount of
change uh uh that you know that that was
thought to be
necessary if if you know I but I I guess
I would say I
don't if if we wanted to make a greater
change um I certainly would be open to
to doing that so so to correct or to
adjust those two parameters possibly
sure okay sure that might make that
might very well make sense
great representative D Lorenzo uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um Mr chair um I'm looking at the
members of the judicial Council IL
please say that um at least two do not
have to be members of the New Hampshire
Bar
Association uh no I think it I think no
two uh five there uh says three of whom
shall be lawyers of wi experience and
two of whom so two of the three lawyers
have to be members of the New Hampshire
Bar Association one would be allowed not
to be um under that paragraph and then
uh the same uh under under uh Roman
numeral 9 which are the appointees of
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
again three would be lawyers two of
those three would have to be members of
the New Hampshire bar so may I follow up
so for the person um who is not a member
of the New Hampshire bar would they be
required to be a member of another bar
association maybe ABA or well interest
no that's that's a that's a good point
uh it doesn't specifically say this and
here um we could change it to say that
they should be a member of you know some
other bar other otherwise it would
basically otherwise it would basically
mean you know a law school graduate who
may never have become a member of any
bar and I'm uh you could have that too
but I think it might it might make sense
to say to change that language to say a
member of
SAR okay may I follow up Okay the reason
that I'm asking is that um your um
members that would be members of the New
Hampshire Bar Association would need to
conform to the rules of professional
conduct um as lawyers but if the person
is not a member of a bar association
there's no requirement of them to follow
a professional contact that's an
excellent point that's a good point and
I mean that might be a reason to say for
example to change to say
um uh three of whom shall be lawyers
admitted to the bar of some state in the
Union two of whom shall be members of
New Hampshire by that's that's an
excellent point very very good point
Thank you Mr
CH representative BOS thank you um thank
you for taking my question the house
just passed a package of bail reforms
and I was wondering whether on page two
um Line 6 through
17 whether this is consistent with the
pack that the house just passed in terms
of bail
reform this is General enough that I
think it is
um but I I I have you know I have not
honestly looked at this
and to be to be completely candid out
the um the whole baale reform thing went
through so many different uh changes I'm
just not
sure
um that wasn't meant in any way as a
gotcha question no no no no I understand
I completely understand I I I looked at
this last night and I didn't have the
time either to go back and forth and
look between the two but I think we
should just make sure as a committee
that this is
consistent sure no that's a good good
point any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
representative We Now call Richard
Saro uh just by way of introduction my
name is Richard Sam Perell uh I am a
lawyer in private practice in exiter but
I am also a member of the judicial
Council and for most of 20 23 I served
as the acting executive director of the
agency um to my right is J Bucky who is
the current executive director of the
agency so for those of you who have not
met him um here he
is
um I think most of the people here
understand sort of the way in which the
judicial Council functions but just by
way of background the judicial council
is a executive branch agency that is
responsible for uh the delivery of legal
services in indent cases the great
majority of those cases being criminal
cases it is overseen and directed by uh
essentially a board of directors the
board of directors has the same name
judicial counsel and some of the changes
that are before you in the statute uh in
the bill today uh pertain to that
membership of the board of directors um
I can uh certainly address uh these
lines uh similar to the way
representative Lynn did if you would
like but I'm also happy to to take
questions from uh the chair or the
members of the
committee that as a sponsor of the bill
I uh I uh testified and I'm not supposed
to ask questions so maybe I won't ask a
question but let me say this if there's
anything that I said that was inaccurate
in terms of the justification for some
of these things could you please correct
my
inaccuracies um I don't think there was
anything that was inac inaccurate um but
maybe just to supplement some
information uh there was some questions
about uh for example the payment of fees
to Witnesses uh and I think those are
very good questions uh just so you know
uh the language that appears before you
is really it's not originally crafted
language in any way it was lifted from
the prior statute um and the reason for
the $12 a day or half day fee is merely
because that's what it used to be and
has been uh at the time uh I was
considering um you know this statute and
uh asking representative Lynn to
consider some legis ation uh I did look
and Survey other states and what they
pay there's a huge range of what states
pay Witnesses for witness fees and for
travel I I don't uh pretend to
understand any uh that there's any
singular logic that applies there and so
I think the simplest thing really was to
look to the prior uh statute that was
repealed and to just use that same
language as a practical matter because
there is no current statute that applies
to witness fees when the judicial
Council receives a request for payment
now for witness fees and
mileage the judicial council is paying
this amount merely because that's the
last amount that we were authorized to
pay so uh certainly if the committee
wants to make changes to those amounts
I'm sure the judicial Council would be
happy to follow those changes but that's
the reasoning by behind that uh with
respect to uh the language about the
replacement of three lawyers with two
lawyers admitted in New Hampshire and um
sort of a a gap as to that third person
uh the reason uh as representative Lynn
was saying is there was someone we
believed would really be good to serve
on the council uh a person who was an
admitted lawyer in the state of Michigan
I believe uh just not admitted in New
Hampshire because of the nature of that
person's work and it got us to thinking
that that person could not be um placed
or nominated to to be serving on the
judicial Council because they're not a
lawyer in New Hampshire but also they
couldn't be on the judicial Council
because they were not a non-lawyer so be
by virtue of the fact that this person
was a lawyer in another state they
couldn't serve in either capacity and so
the language Chang here is merely to
create an opportunity for experienced
invaluable lawyers like that that may
not practice in New Hampshire or maybe
who at one point practiced in New
Hampshire but are now
retired or say a college professor a
university of uh the law school
Professor who for reasons that they
they're not actively practicing are not
admitted to the bar that any one of
those types of people could serve on the
judicial Council because there's uh some
real value and experience maybe to their
background um the one other category
that maybe is is worth me addressing
just briefly is the uh assignment of
council request to the change here uh as
representative Lynn was saying we don't
believe that the circumstance arises
very often where uh we would not follow
the traditional
uh appointment of first the public
defender second contract Council and
third an assigned Council lawyer um but
there are rare circumstances where it
might be in the interest of Justice in
the continuity of councel to be able to
go directly to the second or third tier
of that representation the public
defender in New Hampshire represents 85%
of the criminal defendants uh who
qualify for courta appointed Council but
there are occasions where other council
is appointed um sometimes um as
representative Lynn was saying people
get into further complications and F
receive further charges and it would
make sense to just have one lawyer who
can negotiate maybe all of their cases
or represent that client as a rapport
with that client to continue to do so
without starting the whole process over
so uh we don't believe that those will
be frequent circumstances we don't
believe it'll result in any major cost
um but uh it would be nice to have the
opportunity to assign Council in a way
that not only best serves the defendant
but maybe best serves uh the judicial
process the Justice process
itself representative
Smith hope we don't scare you off um I
noticed that this no fiscal note
and if we were to follow the line that
my colleague representative TR raised as
to do we really want to give 17 cents a
mile I mean is that
fair
um what would happen if we were to bring
those figures up to
Uh current usage maybe for example
saying current you you know the current
rate for reimbursement I know that the
judicial um Council can go before fiscal
to get more money I know that Nina
Gardner did that with great regularity
but with great difficulty um can you
give us an idea of what would happen if
we changed some of those numbers would
they be so
significant that it might create
problems for
you um so I can tell you in the 11
months that I was at the judicial
Council um I
approved I would say less than 30 um
witness fees requests the witness fees
we're talking about here in this Bill
are only those Witnesses who are
subpoena by the defense in Indigent
defense cases so uh when the prosecution
subpoena is a witness it comes from
their pool of funds so I think an answer
to your question the change or the
additional cost uh would likely be very
minimal uh even if you were to change
the mileage rate from 17 cents per mile
to you know the federal rate I I really
think that the change would be um
negligible not negligible but it would
be not anything significant that would
require returning to the legislature and
asking for additional funds so acting in
in good faith and trying to be fair we
would not be creating an untenable
position for you if we were to do so if
we were to do so I don't think so at all
thank you very
much yes representative
ch um thank you um for taking the
question I maybe ask that same question
that representative Smith asked in in in
in the inverse um my understanding from
what you said a minute ago is that your
judicial council is still sort of able
to take these requests in and still able
to to make payments to to folks that
make those requests is that is that but
um is that what you said I I guess what
I'm what I'm wondering and maybe it'll
help is given that this is sort of a
laundry list Bill and this one sort of
might require some tinkering in terms of
what the right numbers would be
um is is there anything that's
preventing the operations that this is
trying to do by not doing by not having
this clause and sort of punting it to a
future perhaps legis legislative action
to to take care of that um thank thank
you for that question um there is a
statute and I I don't have it in front
of me that um requires that the
witnesses be paid but there is currently
no statute that specifies what they're
to be paid or be compensated at so I
don't think it would prevent the
functioning uh of the judicial Council
in any different way than it is now
which is we're just paying at the old
rate but there's really no statutory the
authority to do that um and so you know
if you were to remove that section and
do a separate bill I I don't I don't
think it's easy for me to say I don't
think it will affect this man's job but
um uh but I you know I think giving some
additional thought to that is is
probably not a bad
idea other
questions Mr Bucky oh representative k
please thank thank you Mr chairman
thankk you for taking my question I was
trying to Quick quickly look it up and I
couldn't find it and I will look more if
you don't know the answer to the
question but you mentioned that
currently prosecutors would pay out of
their budget for a witness that was
their witness that
wasn't as part of the Indigent defense
um do you know if their witness rate is
currently statutorily set because I just
want to make sure that we wouldn't be if
we changed this to be the current
mileage that we wouldn't be in conflict
with you know not that it's the same
thing but I don't think it makes sense
that you know a defense witness is
getting paid more than a prosecutor's
witness yeah um thank you for that
question that's a it's an excellent
question my understanding of the law is
that it's the same statutes that apply
uh to everyone that the same statute
that authorizes payment applies to both
prosecution and defense or in any other
case
and uh nobody has a statute that
authorizes the amount of payment so um
the I I I think enacting uh this
legislation would have the same impact
on uh prosecution as it would on defense
it would also apply I mean to other
Indigent cases um that are not criminal
cases but I think it would have a
uniform uh
impact other questions Mr Bucky uh
welcome if there to one to I'm sure what
I'm sure what will be one of many
appearances before the this committee
and others in the legislature
um many happy that's right many happy
appearances U is there anything you'd
like to say we're happy to hear from you
I don't have anything to add at this
time I I agree with everything that's
been said um by my predecessor so thank
you very much for having me here and let
me participate great thank you all right
um I'm next going to call Aaron krian
uh and Miss krian I realized that I did
not cover one section that um was the
subject of an amendment we had discussed
and I hope that you will discuss it uh
because of my uh failure to discuss
it well I have uh I have brought
director Martin to do just that but I I
think I will just briefly before speak
about um the changes that you were
making to 59420 a um I think when
felonies first was rewound this was
rewound this was simply an oversight so
it it currently has a small passage that
would still have uh felonies going to
the Superior Court when that doesn't
occur we currently have some
administrative guidance that we view
this conflict of laws as uh resolvable
by we're going to follow the legislator
later enactment of of the rewind but it
is confusing when people see this in the
statute and uh R Manos you had an
excellent question about how it
conflicts because the same statute is
amended by the bail bills I this um
phrase is not amended but I think you
could have the problem where if one is
printed directly before or after the
other it's like two bills that add a
Section 8 and then you have two section
eights uh potentially in the law so it
it's certainly something in the printing
uh to be conscientious of um before I
turn it over to director Martin to
discuss uh the amendment I know you were
considering are there any questions on
that passage
questions seeing none thank you Miss
Martin good afternoon everyone I am
Diane Martin and I am the director of
the administrative office of the courts
it's really nice to put some faces to
names um as I had the pleasure of
filling in as general counsel in the end
government Affairs coordinator earlier
in the year when we had a bunch of
vacancies so I did get to communicate
with some of you um representative Lynn
has kindly um agreed to bring an
amendment I I believe on our behalf um
to add to this um Bill uh the ability
for us to transfer Appropriations
between and among class lines and
accounting units and it's fairly
straightforward because it is something
that you the legislature already did um
as a footnote to hb2 in the past
um and did for all executive branch
agencies in statute and so what we're
asking for is just to adopt in statute
what you previously did in a footnote
that was not included in this um bial
hb2 and and all that it does is increase
the language in RSA 9 col
16d to
$100,000 to make it consistent both with
executive branch agency authoriz ation
and also the judicial branch prior
authorization and and right now it's the
way the statute stands it's 75,000 want
to increase it to 100 yes and I was not
here when the change happened across the
um State and so I don't know why the
judicial branch was overlooked but it
was added as a footnote to address that
and and it got it fell out this
year questions uh for M
Martin that was my my question was Why
did um it not get added uh this year was
that a decision of the governor was that
a decision of the finance committee in
the house or the Senate I do not believe
it was an INT I was involved in the
operating budget process for the branch
it I think it was just an oversight um I
think it was something that we probably
should have put called to attention and
and did not do and therefore it did not
get
included I Mr chair I'm
just
wondering
um
if we want
to what is the what is the I don't have
the bill in front of me now because I
just turned my page what is the
effective date of this
bill uh upon Passage um except
for the repeal you know so it's it's
upon passage and I am
just concerned about without a fiscal
note on this bill with this that being
added um are
we
overstepping our Authority given that
we're doing this without the involvement
of the finance
committee you know what the oh no no no
go ahead representative
CH this is confusing to me I it looks as
though there is a at least the version I
have has a fiscal note it just doesn't
have the FN in the bill title is that am
I reading this right I'm sorry
but that that's what was confusing me
sorry to jump
in you
know
yeah right undetermined you know what I
you know what I guess um representative
Smith I'm uh I I guess I would be
looking for your guidance on this as I
understand it this would not in any
way
um won't change the budget it won't
change the budget of it would just allow
the to move from from place to place
yeah to move money at a at $225,000
higher rate than they could otherwise so
I think so I think we would call that
Dom minimist don't you think so I would
agree take back my
question other questions for um either
of the witnesses
here thank you very much and thank you
also to Mr shamol and Mr Bucky for uh
uh uh telling me that I didn't make too
many mistakes as I testified about this
thank
you Mr chair do you have a copy of your
I yes I do and I'm you know I'm sorry I
I will I will ask uh our uh assistant to
uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's fine
sure so we have a couple of minutes
before we get to uh
3:15 you know just just so you take
just just literally one one word or one
figure
bu
about you
know right right right right right yes I
know exactly what you
mean uh all right
1489 thank you byebye thank
you oh I what what was that uh yeah no I
just wanted 1274 I just wanted
to
IM
system
probably a lot
ofra you
want
no I was was sing it very I was saying
uh oh we're going to be here till like
you know tomorrow morning it's always
better to be
lucky
[Laughter]
part of right right
right so um I'm it's now 3:15 I'm going
to uh open the hearing on House Bill uh
1489 and I will recognize the uh Prime
sponsor Prime sponsor representative col
colum sorry that's okay I'm used to
it thank thank you Mr chair thank you uh
all the members of the committee uh I
appreciate your time here I have to
apologize because uh I realized as I was
sitting here the first error that I made
was I put down this W House Bill 1484
and it should be 1489 so I quickly made
those
changes um I'm here before you today to
introduce this bill um and it's relative
to town and school ballot recount
appeals uh it's something that I hope
that we can all agree on would be a
simple and fair amendment to change to
RSA 6
66935 and it's regarding the the appeals
in in the recount process um the best
way that I can go about explaining this
is from a a personal experience that I
had in Hillsboro
Dearing in March of 2022 Hillsboro
Dearing uh had their their School Vote
Hillsboro daring is a cooperative and
we're part of 34 which includes
Washington Windsor Hillsboro and Deering
my recount was for both the school
budget the School District budget and
the SAU
budget when I petitioned for this and we
showed up at the um for the
recount uh I learned that the only
ballots that were collected to be
recounted were Hillsboro Dearing ballots
Washington and Windsor were not there I
went through the entire process of the
recount and um asked some questions and
was told that Washington and Windsor was
not part of the recount because I wasn't
a member of Washington and Windsor
School District and that I was a
resident of
Hillsboro so um so that was my first
issue with the recount backing up on the
SAU budget Hillsboro and Dearing when
they voted they failed the budget when
Washington and Windsor voted on the SAU
budget it
passed so as I started my investigation
after um the recount because I planned
on appealing it to the
courts I did some digging and I learned
that Windsor actually didn't have a
paper ballot count like they're supposed
to according to the RSA they did a hand
count or a voice count and I got both
answers with regards to Washington
Washington I was told that it was a hand
count and I was told that it was a paper
count but at that point in time I didn't
bother to push the issue because I knew
it it it was done wrong to begin
with so I had a few issues um regarding
the recount that
I that I told the school that I was
going to challenge um one being that not
all of our ballots were there the second
being that our moderator who was in
charge of this recount actually seemed
ill prepared for the recount he actually
didn't know how many ballots he was
supposed to have to be recounted he
didn't have the supervisor's checklist
um he didn't have any way of verifying
that daring and Hillsboro turned in all
of the ballots and he had no answer when
it came to why Washington and Windsor
were
there and then after doing the recount
which that's a whole other story that
probably should be addressed in a
different bill
um the the recount was done with my
observers they had three tables set up
with the school board members doing the
recounts I had three
observers everything went fairly well in
that process but when it came time to
tallying their counts of each of the
three tables the moderator went behind a
box and did the tally came up with his
tally and announced it which happened to
be the exact same as what was published
and I asked him does anybody get to see
your math does anybody get to check it
and again he didn't respond and didn't
allow me the opportunity or any of my
observers the opportunity to check the
math so after this when I told the
school that I was going to appeal it I
then started the process of making some
phone calls and really diving into this
much deeper before I filed with the
Superior Court in
Hillsboro and um I got some great
responses I I contacted the Secretary of
State's office I contacted the Attorney
General's office I went through the rsas
as best as I could and as best as I
understood and I got a very thorough and
and uh informative response from Bud
Fitch from the Secretary of State's
office and I've included his email there
as well for you guys to look at and he
set me on the right direction and
confirmed that what was done actually
was not to statute um so I then
proceeded to file my claim with the
court and I got to the point of the
claim with the court where it was going
to cost me
$280 to file this claim to petition at
the court that this recount was not done
properly and at that point in time I
stopped um I I took a lot of things into
consideration at that point in time um
you know I really wanted to know what
was I going to get out of my $280 right
so you before I took that out of our
family budget what was this going to
give me it was going to confirm that
what Bill Fitch said and what I knew was
that I was right um you know it's not
always the best thing to be right I mean
that's not that's not the win um what I
wanted to have fixed was the process and
that was really my objective and this
was fixing the process uh you know the
courts probably would have said the
moderator needs better training so that
he understands how to perform a recount
they probably would have gone to Windsor
and said hey you guys need to follow the
RSA and um we probably would have gone
back to the default that the SAU
probably may have failed because we
wouldn't have been able to verify it
without ballot votes from Windsor so it
may have failed but that would have
really only been a $9,000 change in the
budget so at the end of the day I
started thinking about this saying
what's the best course of action and my
best course of action that I felt was
taking it to our legislative body to see
see if we can correct this um so that if
a person like me who wasn't a
representative at the time um wants to
challenge a recount that I should um one
I have the right to do that but I should
have a little bit of protection if the
court does find in favor of me if the
court found in favor of me I would have
been out my $280 and I would have had
the bragging rights of saying I was
right um however you know and the school
would have just said okay we're going to
fix this
so my mission was to add a little bit
more teeth into it for the school to get
it right so my request is just simply to
um allow the the the grieved person the
the grieved person to be able to collect
any attorney fees and court cost fees if
the court finds in their favor and if
the court doesn't then the money comes
out of my pocket and it was my gamble my
loss so that's the the context of this
bill and where I'm coming from on this
so you know in the end you know after
after doing all of this you know I
experienced firsthand why people don't
push their the challenge to our
municipalities and schools and there
were many people when I was going around
asking to them for them to sign the
petition there were many people who told
me not to bother that it was just a
waste of time and it was an exercise and
futility um and I I just believed
different and pressed on um and I just
got to the point where I said I'm not
spending $300 or $280 of my and I want
to go a different route with this that
will help people in the future who want
to follow the same
path so here I am in front of you with
this bill I'm prepared to answer any
questions um but I would like to ask the
committee to please review the data that
I've provided um and make a
recommendation of ought to
pass thank you questions for members of
the committee you know I guess I have I
do have one question am I understanding
this if we were to adopt this this would
apply to any recount is that words it
wouldn't be limited to municipal or
School uh elections it would be any
recount no I made the amendment to the
municipal and school I did not go up to
the state level I kept it at the local
level
okay all right so it's only all right so
it only be
um only uh for Municipal School all
right right only amending RSA 669 um 35
okay all right other questions uh for
this
witness thank you very much thank you
that was
easy uh is there anyone else who wishes
to testify on House Bill
1489 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1489 and I think we are uh
done